this is jaco podcast number 138 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening sir
the young seal whispered in a faint
voice come here our hands were clasped
in handshake not a formal handshake like
two businessman but palm to palm with
thumbs wrapped around the back of the
hand like an arm-wrestling contest a
handshake of brotherhood the young seal
was feeling the morphine I saw in his
eyes but he was still there still
conscious and aware he was everything
the young man should be smart brave
athletic funny loyal and tough he'd been
shot in the leg about a half an hour
before I found out later that my key
mansour a young seal machine gunner had
run out into heavy enemy gunfire and
dragged this seal out of a war-torn
Street in the Milad district in the city
of Ramadi the violent heart of the
insurgency in Iraq the wounded seal now
lay on a gurney in Charlie med the camp
Ramadi field hospital where US military
surgical teams worked furiously to save
the lives of gravely wounded troops
almost everyday the bullet a mammoth
armor-piercing 7.62 by 54r millimeter
round with a steel core had entered his
leg at the lower thigh ripped the part
flesh and bone inside his leg and exited
in his upper thigh close to the groin it
was hard to say if he would keep his leg
from the looks of the wound my guess was
no he would lose it
the wounded seals grip on my hand
tightened and he pulled me in drawing me
just inches from his face I could tell
he wanted to say something to me so I
turned and put my ear to his next to his
mouth I wasn't sure what to expect was
he scared or angry or depressed that he
might lose his leg was he nervous about
what might happen next was he confused
he took a breath and then whispered sir
let me stay let me stay please don't
make me go home I'll do anything I'll
sweep up around the camp I can heal here
please please please just let me stay
with the task unit there you go not
scared not angry not depressed that he
might lose his leg only concerned that
he might have to leave our task unit
task unit bruiser our task unit our
lives this seal was our first
significant casualty we had had guys
catch some frag on previous operations
we had had some very close calls
but this was the first seal wounded from
task unit bruiser whose life would be
forever changed by a grave combat injury
even if he kept his leg the damage was
so substantial that it didn't seem
possible he would ever fully regain the
extraordinary athleticism he had
displayed previously and yet this seal
was only concerned that he would let me
down let the task unit down let it death
his platoon and his team down
this was a man this was a true friend a
brother this was a hero young brave and
without question more concerned for his
friends than for his own life I was
moved
I felt tears welling up in my eyes I
fought them back then I swallowed the
lump in my throat this was no time to
break down I was supposed to be the
leader then he needed me to be strong
and that right there is from the opening
chapter of a book called the dichotomy
of leadership which is actually a new
book and it was written by me and my
brother
Lafe babban and Lafe has been on this
podcast before we wrote extreme
ownership together we obviously served
in tasking at bruiser together and he
was on this podcasts
he was the first guest he's the been the
guest the most times he was on 11 he was
on 34 65 and 114 if you want to go get
some background on life but I'm glad to
say that he is actually back here with
us again
so lave babban welcome back it's good to
be back thanks fat male yeah right on
man and it's it's good to have you back
because we're done writing and editing
this book which feels good it does feel
good spending a lot of work but it's
been awesome
to it and dependent will tell those kind
of stories like you just read and and
even though I've read that now a hundred
times
it's just takes me immediately back to
that situation and it's just a shortener
and we were able to work with some
incredible incredible seals like like
that young man yeah no doubt about it it
the it's it's weird when you're writing
a book and you're and then you're
rereading it and rereading it and
rereading it and like you said every
time I would be reading these these
sections you know you you just get that
you just you just can't help but go back
there you just can't help but go back
there and this was definitely there was
some there were some parts of this book
that I was writing that were definitely
hard to write and even hard to edit you
know even this being one of them and I'm
glad that we're able to share the
stories of guys like that and that
particular individual which I don't talk
about this
the book but he he kept his leg thank
God
and he he kept getting after it for
years in years and he kept trained in
jiu-jitsu and he's a total stud maybe
sometime he'll come on the podcast on
who knows but what a great guy now you
want you also kind of kicked off the
book with what I thought was a what was
like a solid way to kick it off and you
should you should go into that I know we
were trying to pick out some good
sections here but I thought the opener
that you put in which you opened with a
phrase that we've been using quite a bit
lately but kick off that that
introduction to the book dichotomy
leadership stand by to get some said
someone over the inner squad radio and
the calm demeanor you might expect the
flight attendant telling airline
passengers to stow their trade tables
for landing the street in front of us
had emptied of people like magic the
local citizens had all suddenly
disappeared and we knew what that meant
enemy attack was imminent the hair on
the back of my neck stood at rigid
attention after many a vicious gunfight
in Ramadi
stand by to get some was a running joke
that eased the tension right when we
knew trouble was coming the more
nonchalantly it could be said under the
diarist of circumstances the funnier it
was it was broad daylight as our patrol
of seals and Iraqi soldiers made its way
on foot down the narrow city street
bordered by high concrete walls on both
sides suddenly the world exploded dozens
of bullets snapped to the air each with
a sharp supersonic crack and smashed
into the concrete wall next to me with
thunderous impact shards of concrete
flew everywhere the heavy volleys of
incoming fire sounded like multiple
jackhammers simultaneously chewing up
the street and the walls all around us
we had walked right into an enemy
buzzsaw insurgent fighters hit us from
multiple directions with belt-fed
machine guns I couldn't see them or
where they were shooting from
but the numb
/ of enemy bullets flying through the
air around us was crazy there was no
place to hide with high walls on both
sides the narrow south-central Ramadi
Street provided no cover the only thing
between us and the enemy machine guns
was a single parked car on the side of
the road some distance up the block and
the typical trash shown about the patrol
was in a dual column formation each
column split on opposite sides of the
street hunkered close to the walls there
was nothing to get behind that could
protect us from bullets but we did have
something on our side devastating
firepower we fully expected a firefight
on every patrol into this enemy hill
neighborhood and we rolled in heavy each
squad of eight seals packed at least
four belt-fed machine guns to suppress
any enemy attack we encountered when we
came under fire our immediate response
with violent and overwhelming gunfire
provided the only answer cover and move
having learned to the humbling
experience of months of urban combat
task unit bruiser had had plenty of
practice in this fundamental gun
fighting principle within nanoseconds
the seals were the big machine guns up
front unleash the most ruthless and
lethal barrage of fire you could imagine
despite the intensity and violence of
the clothes urban combat I couldn't help
but smile couldn't help with smile yeah
that's we've said this before but
obviously guys that have been to war
usually that's the best thing in their
life and the best experiences they've
had in their lives and it gives you that
that type of feeling right there of
which you can't help but smile and then
you know as I just talked about and as
we both know it's also the worst days of
our lives are also there and and we know
that you know people in the military all
feel you know most of them feel the same
way that you have your best days and and
your worst days there and it's
interesting you cover and move it's just
it always comes back to cover and move
in these these gunfights and you know
client we were working with recently and
you know remember he switched around
cover and move and made it a second and
put put simple first
it's like well there's a reason why that
that exists that way cover move is first
because if you're not working together
as a team there's no there's nothing to
even keep simple that's not happening
you just you need to start off with
cover move team work is critical and
obviously we just read a couple of sort
of war story ish type things but like
extreme ownership this book's kind of
setup the same way as extreme ownership
I mean well I'm not kind of it is set up
the same way
his extreme ownership which is a story
about combat that reveals a principle
and then actually state what the
principle is and then we use a business
example that shows how this principle
applies in civilian life and usually in
the business world in fact always in the
business world that's those are the
examples that we use although we could
probably do another book that was about
how these principles apply to you're
under nine year old soccer team or your
relationship with your spouse or your
relationship with your teenage daughters
two of them or your relationship with
your teenage son one of them or your
relationship with your nine-year-old
daughter or your what do you got threes
and fours a three and a two year old
yeah get some absolutely what it can
absolutely any of those situation I
think that was that was what was amazing
about extreme ownership to see how
people apply that in so many aspects of
their lives and now I think with
dichotomy leadership it's exactly the
same thing yeah
it applies across all aspects of a
professional and personal life well
who's here too because when I win
you know when I got out of the team's
like I didn't understand I didn't
understand the broad application of what
we knew I didn't I mean when I started
working with civilian companies then
it's like oh well this is your problem
you don't keep things simple enough for
this is your problem you don't have
decentralized command so you're trying
to control all the decisions make its
but as soon as we realized well and I
realized it was like okay applies to
this company what about this company and
okay what about this company and you
just realize okay and that's when I
started just seeing it everywhere and
and I think yeah exactly right the
dichotomy of leadership is the same way
and it
well like I said it's not just a book of
war stories the the point of the book is
to make people better leaders is to give
them leadership tools including me
including you like when you write stuff
down you understand it better and so you
know part of writing these books is like
okay how can I capture these lessons for
myself and of course it's nice that
other people can grab them then and and
look through them but like I said it's
not it's not just about war stories but
to make people better leaders and I
think I think we covered that pretty
well in sort of in the intro of the book
and just a couple paragraphs and you
should hit that part that we talked
about earlier where it just kind of
gives the overall the overall view or
the the high-level view of the topic of
the book every behavior or
characteristic carried out by a leader
can be taken too far leaders can become
too extreme and upset the balance
required to effectively lead a team when
balance is lost
leadership suffers and the team's
performance rapidly declines even the
fundamental principles of combat
leadership and extreme ownership can get
out of balance a leader can cover and
move too much and step on the toes of
other leaders departments or divisions a
plan can be too simple and failed to
cover life the contingencies a team
could go too far with prioritize and
execute resulting in target fixation and
loss of situational awareness on newly
emerging problems and threats even
decentralized command can be taken too
far when too much autonomy is given to
subordinate leaders who then don't fully
understand sortie jet goals and how to
execute in support of those goals and
this idea continues on with just about
everything a leader does leaders must be
close with their people but not too
close that it becomes a problem they
must hold the line with discipline but
they must not become tyrannical a leader
can even become too extreme with extrem
ownership when a leader takes so much
ownership of everything in his or her
world that members of the team feel
there's nothing left for which they can
take ownership when this happens team
members will execute only at the boss's
specific direction without any route
ownership or buying themselves resulting
in a team far less capable of overcoming
obstacles and accomplishing the mission
therefore balance and leadership is
crucial to victory you can't say that
one enough and you literally can't say
that one enough I was thinking so when
you have the same word too many time on
times on a page it's it's not good
writing right it's not good to use the
same word over and over again so I
remember there was times we would have
the word balance like nine times in a
paragraph but there's it's like hey
there's no real other way to say what
we're trying to say you gotta balance
these things and it's interesting too as
as you're reading that I'm just thinking
of all the different situations we've
been in in the last few years with
echelon font where we've seen every
single one of these things you know the
person that comes up it will keep this
plan simple and then they don't think of
any contingencies or hey I'm just trying
to cover it move and that means I'm
gonna call it do the job for them and
all of a sudden they're making everyone
mad because they're stepping on
everyone's toes a decentralized command
where no one knows what's going on
because it's okay I'm more hands-off
leader I'm using decentralized command
but boss what in God's name do you
actually want us to do so all these
things are are are we've lived we've
lived film now and it became really
evident even though we have you know
that's the last chapter the last chapter
in extreme ownership is the dichotomy
leadership and discipline equals freedom
and you know we put it in there because
we knew it was important but now after
working with more people over the past
few years it's become so obvious that
this is like such a critical the being
able to balance balance balance balance
I even use that word nine times in every
paragraph because that's what you have
to do if you're a leader and and we
talked about this too in the opening of
in the opening of the book and the a/o
in the opening of dichotomy leadership
we talked about how one of the problems
with the book extreme ownership is the
title extreme ownership because it made
everyone just want to get extreme with
everything I'm gonna be super extreme
and so that means you know what I'm
gonna do when we get extreme on the own
everything and we that was one of the
earliest things that I started noticing
was people that took so much ownership
so on the leader on
charge and I take so much ownership of
everything that everyone below me in the
chain of command there's nothing left
for them to own and and all of a sudden
they're just feel like hey they're just
along for the ride and there's gonna do
what they're told to do and all their
initiative is gone and they don't they
don't even have AI they don't they don't
it's not that they don't believe but
they just think okay we're just gonna do
it we're told so it's not their plan and
so they're gonna do the best of their
ability but it's not there they don't
own it so all those things that you just
talked about are things that we've we've
now seen and there are things that I
struggle with you know I think there's
there things that you struggle I think
we each of us struggle with them it's
the hardest part about leadership and as
we've seen that over and over again that
that you know that brief introduction
that we gave it in Chapter 12 of extreme
ownership
you know introduced the concept but this
dives so much deeper into those
challenges and I think that's what what
I love about this book is it answers the
the questions to that we get most often
about about how to balance that because
that's the hardest part and it's so
difficult to do and I remember in our
first muster there was a question about
you know can you take you know can
extreme leadership go too far I actually
answered the question well I think if
you're properly understanding what
extreme ownership means no but but you
actually has like absolutely you can
take too much ownership and I think
that's what people take that as well
I've got to do everything like know you
you're responsible for everything that's
what extreme ownership means but
certainly you can you can absolutely
take too much ownership where no one's
doing anything and I think we explain
that pretty well in this book and and
this this book was written just like
extreme ownership the economy leadership
was written to help leaders as a
reference manual and if it's something
that you know if I see pages like we see
so many Congress if extreme ownership I
mean I want to see pages that are
underlined that are highlighted there
tad that are there utilized by leaders
and and if we've done that and this is a
manual that helps a leaders lead better
and be better people and lead better
teams and then this will have
accomplished this mission you know what
school is is I think think it's very
similar to the fact that with extreme
ownership right with that attitude with
that attitude when you get in that
mindset you start seeing it everywhere
and you start when someone makes an
excuse you you
immediately go that's an excuse like
echo is giving you a hard time about
your your lack of a haircut and and you
know you were you were saying that yes
it's my fault and we were laughing about
it right and and of course I was I was
like well you know I should have told
you you know there's gonna be a time
line and you need to get a haircut
before but you know we're joking about
it
but in the same time that we're joking
about it the fact that like you brought
that echo that up is a real thing and
for us to be sitting here joking about
it means that we actually think about it
we actually every time you you know
Leif's making a joke and excuse like a
chocolate he's it's like we all know and
it's a it's it's a it sinks in and it
becomes really like for someone to make
an actual excuse becomes really really
hard and I think for me that's one thing
that I've benefited over the last few
years I've seen other people what you
it's it becomes when you're aware of it
when you're aware of it the balance
becomes much much easier to see and
that's what I think is gonna be very
helpful about this book is people won't
know that they're out of balance that's
the biggest problem biggest problems
they don't know they're thinking my guys
are taking any initiative what's wrong
with them and it's like well you're
micromanaging them you've gone too far
in that direction you've gone too far in
controlling everything that they do they
think that that's the they think that if
you want them to do something that
you're gonna tell them to do it and
other than that they're gonna sit there
and stand by and wait for orders and
it's like no so wait and you if you
don't understand that you can be out of
balance then you won't recognize that
but if you know hey my guys aren't
taking it in any initiative I wonder
what's wrong with them well actually
maybe it's me maybe it's me and maybe I
am micromanaging them so much that I've
beaten the initiative out of them so
what I need to do is back off a little
bit and give them some leeway and give
them some ownership of what they're
doing and let them make some decisions
down there and if if you do that then
you start seeing it come back and start
seeing them take initiative and you feel
good and that's a you know one of the
chapters in the book is actually that
right there where I talk about my first
deployment to Iraq where I where I first
got to Iraq my first time in combat I
was just basically wanted to own
everything because that was
that's my personnel do I come to take
ownership of this and then I realize my
guys Michael you know they're not really
taking the initiative all I wanted to
take well why is that it's because I'm
micromanaging them and finally luckily
we got overwhelmed with operations we
had so many operation to conduct me I
was like I can't I can't manage all
these I can't oversee everything that's
happening and I had to cut the guys
loose and as soon as I caught him loose
and said hey you got this and you got
that and you got the other thing the
guys just started stepping up and
running everything like I knew the like
like of course they could cuz they're
freaking highly capable guys and they
started kicking ass and I realize I
don't even barely even need to be here
right barely even need to be here
whereas in the beginning I thought oh
this is all if I wasn't for me you know
and I'm probably talking about a period
of a few weeks of me trying to
micromanage everything so I think what's
gonna be beneficial about this book is
that people will see how they can get
out of balance and and they'll also see
that that balance pertains to just about
everything and every trait that you have
that's positive as a leader you can
overdo and you can turn it into a
negative trait if you go too far so you
know watch out for that you can't forget
a watch after that it is easy for us to
see you know we always talk about the
attachment attachments so important and
and for us with you know through our
company Isilon fronts we're working with
these leaders and working with these
companies you you can see it you know it
just it just stands out so obvious that
someone is you know they're trying to
cover and move by helping another
department and yet they're stepping on
people's toes and they're pissing people
off and you know like why are you you
know you're trying to do my job and make
me lift that yeah and and they get there
that were like well I'm trying to cover
up just right I'm told me I'm just
trying to help and then you're saying
well you have to be careful about that
you have to you have to balance it and
so once yeah it is the absolute most
common problem we see all the time and
and even for you know folks that have
read extreme ownership you know three or
four you know multiple times that that
are really trying hard to be better
leaders they struggle with that and this
is something to help them and help
leaders everywhere you know and we wrote
the book to so that it could be read
it's a follow on certainly a sequel you
gave me a chance to correct that
why would you say what you say oh no you
were talking about jaws to your podcast
114 and I said it's not a sequel it's a
standalone book but it absolutely is a
sequel follow-on book it expands on the
concepts however we did write it so that
it is a standalone book and you can read
you can reduce your motion if you have
if you can read the economy without
having read extreme ownership you know
you'll certainly understand it and be
able to put yeah but you'd understand
the concepts better if you read extreme
ownership first no question and then you
jump into dichotomy which yeah like you
said can you read it alone sure you can
I guess there's echo we need like some
kind of a movie reference here like yeah
I'm thinking Turk could you see
Terminator 2 yes on its own right but
you will you will get more out of it if
you saw Terminator 1 first yeah correct
thing with look at me just nailing right
here yeah so Rambo right First Blood
Part two same deal where you could watch
just ramble and being pretty pretty
happy about it but hold on now my
problem with that is we know that
Terminator 2 is equivalent in quality to
Terminator 1 correct correct right
correct yeah right MAIF I think so Oh
2002 is awesome except fuck it are they
saying are we saying that better Rambo
to which I don't even think I've seen
First Blood Part 2 yeah I don't is a
recent that's the same level of quality
as Rambo for what you get there for
there and that's what I think we're
answer I figure I mean I'm not saying
that was Jaws to which jaws one which is
a masterpiece just right masterpiece
Jaws jaws 1 jaws time called jaws one
she called jaws right jaws too
problematic we got issues what I'm
saying is we're more like the Terminator
scenario gotcha or alien I was gonna say
you can totally watch that movie
standalone a but obviously gives you
some more context if you watch the first
one but I think the second was actually
better yeah the first do you feel like
do you feel like dichotomies better I
actually do I actually do feel I feel
it's better I mean I'm interested to
hear what readers think about it but I I
think that it's more useful and
applicable to
two leaders I mean we have three years
additional leadership experience and not
only evaluating our experiences in
combat and in the SEAL Teams but but now
working with hundreds of leaders and I
mean really we're talking you know a
couple of hundred plus companies that
we've worked with in that time easily
you know between Jessie me and you
probably not that's not even counting
some of the other members of our team so
we've seen this in in a whole lot of
different scenarios and and I think it
really addresses the it's a direct
application to the problems that we see
so I'm pretty hopeful and I'm looking
forward to to read her feedback on was
it easier for you to write yes yeah I
mean for me it definitely was
and I say easier just because we've we
well we became better writers as we
wrote extreme ownership extreme
ownership the first version that we did
extreme ownership was in the third
person and I forget why we even did that
but we was about these two guys named
Lafe and Jocko it was about I don't know
I forgot kind of forgive I think it was
a recommendation that came to us from
literary aids yeah the publisher whoever
and we know then we finally had to say
yeah we're not doing that yeah
yeah but you had friend of yours that
talks about themselves in the third
person that you know yeah we're not
gonna do yeah so and it's weird because
there's the the book there's there's a
couple books I've done on the podcast
clay pigeons the saint-lo by Glover
Jones who's the guy that you know
hackworth wrote about he wrote the book
clay pitch is a clay pigeon to say hello
and it's in the third-person about a guy
named major Jones and it's him and he
writes a thing in the beginning and says
hey I didn't feel comfortable talking
about myself so I did it wrote it this
way it's like okay and the the only
thing I would say that's cool about it
you could you could kind of give an
outside view but the thing that's not
cool about it he couldn't be I was
thinking this right now which is kind of
what I want to hear and that's why I
normally cover books that are
first-person people that actually
experience it but he's a guy that did a
couple other people of when you're done
when you're Glover Jones though and
you're you're david hackworth see daddy
you can yeah you can do whatever you
want to do what you want for sure now
that's another part that's again you
know we've we've in this book we set it
up the same way with combat story
principle followed by a business example
but one thing that I think and this is
feedback that that we both got that I
certainly got was that for what for
because the consequences are so high in
combat it makes the principle very clear
and even though people might know well
I've never been in combat but they
understand that if we're not working
together as a team doing cover move we
will die and so when they understand
that they go okay now that means if I'm
not working with the other department
then we're gonna lose money or we're not
gonna complete our mission and we're not
gonna take market share yes so I think
one of the strongest points of of
extreme ownership that we did again is
the combat stories to to sort of
introduce the principles and plus it's
cool to hear cool stories like that but
one of them I think chapter three
another another one that we pulled out
that said it'd be good to sort of cover
this one real quick as you opened up
chapter three with a little a little bit
get some I guess we could say and hit
that one man I don't want to I want to
hear that one I want to hear the Texas
Batman get crazy in in Ramadi in 2006
this is bringing back some awesome
memories here
bright orange tracers streaked like
laser beams just a few feet over our
heads
each supersonic Bullock zipping past
with a thunderous crack holy shit
thought as we quickly duck down behind
the roof wall those are friendly
shooting at us I looked over at Dave
Burke who crouched down nearby like the
other seals on the roof with us we tried
to stay low enough not to get her head
shot off Dave looked back at me and
shook his head with a smile makes to
humor and concern that's not cool Dave
said the understatement of the year Dave
Burke was a US Marine Corps major a
fighter pilot by trade he had been the
lead instructor at the legendary u.s.
Navy fighter weapons school
known as Top Gun David left the cockpit
behind a volunteered to serve on the
ground as a forward air controller in
the most dangerous place in Iraq Ramadi
he led a supporting arms liaison team
assault attached to the US Marine Corps
v air naval gunfire liaison company Dave
and his 12 Marines from Salt six
accompany charlie platoon to coordinate
with the aircraft supporting this
operation and the skies overhead they
patrolled him with us on foot to
spearhead the operation ahead of the US
Army and Iraqi army units a u.s. tank
200 yards away had fired a burst from
its heavy machine gun directly over our
position it was friendly fire a blue on
blue in US military parlance to be
killed or horribly wounded by enemy fire
was one thing to be killed by our own
American forces was something much worse
that was way too close for comfort I
thought in the seconds following as I
crouched as low as possible behind the
low concrete wall that was our only
means of cover we had to shut that down
immediately and alert the tank that we
were friendly forces to do so I had to
contact the specific tank commander
directly via radio and tell them to
cease fire
the tanks heavy machine gun was the 50
caliber m2 browning known as the MA
deuce it backed a hell of a punch and US
military service since 1933 it had
proven its deadly effectiveness in every
American war since World War one each
massive round could take a man's head
clean off or remove the bulk of his
chest cavity it could also punch right
through concrete walls like the one we
were hiding behind we had just received
a fully automatic burst of probably a
dozen rounds in a matter of seconds if I
didn't shut down the fire immediately
and let the u.s. tank know we were
friendlies it could mean horrible wounds
and death for a number of US
blue-on-blue it's even in extreme
ownership we talked there's three
episodes of blue-on-blue potential or
Butley out with with Chris potentially
shooting the American trooper that was
enough in a building the Bradley getting
ready to light up stoners guys in
and also the blue and blue that the book
starts off with there's it's it's
interesting and a reality of war that we
talk about blue or blue a lot in that
urban environment the other thing I
noticed is did you I don't mean to
accuse you here like you know on this in
this format but each massive round could
take a man's head clean off is that not
just jack from Clint Eastwood right
there you go bald man that's Cory for
Magnum s Dirty Harry right I can neither
confirm tonight look at you
there's uh the did you consult with that
go for you know party you're right in
here echo and I we see at out in the
movie cooks yes there was a little there
was a use of parlance in there too that
in the parlance are our time so you
through a little little Big Lebowski in
there that we had previously look that
was a crazy situation and we were I
thought we'd done everything what was so
crazy about that situation for us is I
thought we'd done everything in our
power to mitigate the risk of that and
let everybody know where we were marked
our position you know talk talked and
coordinated with people and and to still
get shot at by friendlies
you know they that was that was crazy
and Dave and I were sitting at each
other like man this is good this isn't
good at all so it was it was a I was
foam of that radio trying to get and
talk to them immediately and thank God
as we talked about on previous podcasts
you'd come down on us to be able to use
to be able earn how to use those radios
ourselves and not just rely on the radio
Minh and I was able to swap over and and
make direct comment that take and and
and get them a ceasefire and that's one
of the things that I like to help
completely held the line on and and you
know you talk about in the book how
there's some other things where I
allowed a little bit of slack and you
actually you actually kind of capture
that in a couple pages later that I
pulled up here it's a middle of page 76
punched through that little section
right there and I think it's a it's a
good good kind of captures what we're
talking about in terms of and you were
saying this to me early earlier today
you're like everyone thinks jockle would
just be like oh you're gonna
shut up and do what I tell you to do and
it's like well actually there's some
things I'm gonna tell you that
but there's something it's gonna there's
gonna be a balance well you actually you
never said you shut up and do do us do
what I tell you to do right I'm sure you
probably wanted to but many many times
yeah and still do I'm sure often but
there is it's not effective it's never
affected to do that and I think so many
leaders that want to just you know why
won't they just do what I tell them to
do it's it's people get really
frustrated by that but obviously they're
you got to hold the line you absolutely
have to hold the line you know and if
you do relent it on on us being able to
learn how to use my radios I mean that
could have cost lives right there
another verse arounds comes to comes
through the roof wall or we take a main
gun round now you're talking to the
cannon on the tank the 120 millimeter
main gun round you know just smash
through both sides of walls you know it
would have it would have an absolute
catastrophic those guys think you know
they're under attack they're shooting
back at what they think is enemy then
even realize it
and it's not like they were they were
not ready to use those main gun rounds
if they had to they were they were
putting some buildings down over there
for sure and that's and that's the hard
part right is that you've got to hold
the line and there's standards that
can't be compromised and you've got it
you're failing your team and you're
failing as a leader if you're not
keeping those standards high and making
sure the team achieves them and yet also
you can't be the unrelenting taskmaster
the slave driver that just smashes
people down it says shut up and do it at
eight yeah this is something I bring up
a lot when I'm working with companies is
like do you actually want people to do
except to do whatever you tell them to
do and the the the immediate answer is
like well yeah I just want everyone to
shut up and do what I tell them to do
well the actual answer is no you don't
want that if you're a good leader what
you want is if I tell Lafe hey go take
that building over there and you say to
me no and I say why not you say well
there's an AED in the front yard and
we'll all get killed if we go there I'm
go okay thank you now as opposed to
yours gonna blindly do whatever I tell
you to do well then that's going to be
problematic so there's a balance in this
too and and that's something that we
talk about all the time but to surround
you don't want to surround yourself with
yes-man
jasmine and
we I've seen plenty of companies where
the boss man has surrounded himself with
yes men and they yes themselves into the
grave because they're the the everyone's
just agreeing Oh yep we'll do that that
sounds like a great plan boss oh yeah oh
yes boss that sounds like a great plan
boss and and the next thing you know
someone along the line should have said
hey boss that doesn't make any sense hey
boss
like oh we got a good relationship with
these people over here but you know what
they're raising the price a little bit
we don't want to work with them anymore
okay well let's think about that you
know that that that's one of our biggest
suppliers do we really want to nix our
relationship with our biggest supplier
does that make sense
well you know they're getting in our
face now a yes-man will be like that's
right boss we don't take no crap from no
one we'll screw those guys but maybe you
want someone below you in the chain of
command says hey boss let's think about
this that's our biggest supplier if we
cut them off and demand goes up we won't
be able to service our customers that
could be problematic wouldn't you agree
how about we negotiate with them so
there's my point is you don't just want
people you know just don't want to be
surrounded by yes men you want people
are gonna question you you want people
that are gonna be that's why I like you
so much laughs could you you questions
you have no problem question see what
I'm saying the humble not passive
I've never never been bested but I think
this this year page 76 that's a good
that's a good little way to capture what
we were talking about as I reflected
upon Jacko's demonstration of a leaders
responsibility to ensure standards are
maintained I thought about the times in
my career when I failed to do so as a
young leader I knew there were times we
needed to improve our performance do
another run to the kill house where we
practice close quarters combat or add an
additional rehearsal to ensure we were
fully prepared yet in those moments I
sometimes hadn't held a line I hadn't
pushed the team hard enough any
additional work a sign of the team was
going to get pushed back and generate
complaints and there were times when I
let things slide confusing the idea of
taking care of your people with allowing
them not to work as hard but in the end
that resulted in mediocre performance
and the team never got better never held
each other accountable this was a
failure of leadership
my leadership I also recognized the
dichotomy there were other times when I
was overbearing I insisted on doing
things a certain way because it was my
way or harmed on trivial matters that
were strategically unimportant thinking
I was doing right by holding the line it
caused unnecessary friction stifle
growth and inhibited junior leaders on
the team from stepping up it prevented
us from functioning properly with
effective decentralized command had seen
and worked for numerous leaders
throughout my Navy career who had been
overbearing and it wasn't the way I
wanted to lead some of them imposed
harsh discipline screamed at their
people and crushed the morale of the
team no one wanted to follow them they
might accomplish an immediate task but
in the long run the team's growth was
smothered often their negative example
stood starkly in my mind I never want to
be a leader like that there you go
the tyrannical leader that's running
around screaming and everyone and and
and like you just said they'll get some
little tasks accomplished and they
actually think that what's horrible is
they get some little task accomplished
because they screamed and yelled and it
reinforces that behavior and so they
become even more tyrannical and yell and
scream even more and they never see the
fact that acting that way it'll get you
a little some little short-term thing
done but you'll never get everything you
can how the people you never get
everything you can out of somebody that
you've beaten into submission you
they're not gonna perform to their
fullest potential and capability and
that's just where you're gonna be that's
just where you're gonna be the other
thing it takes this is this is one of
those things like if you've got
something that's hard to do right you've
got something that the team has got to
dude it's hard to do and you're
wishy-washy about it you know it's the
right thing to do but you're wishy-washy
about how you approach the team with
doing it you it's not gonna happen it's
just not gonna happen I'm reading
another book right now by a guy that was
in Vietnam with Hackworth and he's
saying just he would just lay down the
law like how core through second oh
we're doing this this is what we're
gonna do this is how it's gonna be and
that's that's what it is
you know I've got so many
samples from my career but I'll tell you
really kind of a lame one but it's it's
worth telling
so back Buchannon dude guess what we
used to do in the teams we used to drink
beer a lot of it and that was kind of
like a you know we're in the steals you
know we were drinking frog men and
that's cool
and I was in a seal platoon where we
drank a lot even more than a normal seal
platoon which is puts you in the running
for a lot and this is back in the 90s
there's no war going on and I've said
this before kind of the way that we
proved ourselves because there's a
certain level of sacrifice you have to
make to prove to your teammates that
you're like you're willing to sacrifice
well one of the ways that you can
sacrifice is you can just drink a lot
and prove that you can go all night and
go hard and still get up the next day
and so I was in a co platoon where we
drank a lot just about everyone in the
chain of command except for the
commander the OIC but everyone else you
know we drank hard and you know we we
partied in whatever and we were a
shipboard we were an Oracle attune so we
were deploying on board a ship and when
we were getting ready to deploy on the
ship it was kind of like oh well you
know we'll just we'll just because
you're not allowed to drink any alcohol
on the ship you're not having alcohol
you can after 90 days at sea you can get
a beer day they gave morning love
was it 45 well back when I was so yeah
you get one beer 45 days so he gave me
they gave us a two beers but I will say
they gave us Foster's so they were big
oil cans right but you're living large
yeah I I did too - beer days and one
deployment anyways you're not allowed
other than that you're not allowed to
drink that's the rules and so I think it
wasn't like we openly discuss like how
are we gonna smuggle beer maybe we did a
little bit but our bosses came down like
yeah well there's no drinking on no
drinking on the ship and we were like
okay those littles they just came down
and put the rules down like hey no
drinking on the ship and I had respect
for my office my student at the time had
respect for my platoon chief at the time
and they came down and said yeah well
there's no drinking on ship so don't
even think about it we're like okay cool
that's the law came down and we just got
on board we just got on board with it
whereas if it would have been well you
know a little bit of wishy-washy us
us young 'if three z4s Andy fives if
they would've been remotely wishy-washy
we don't like oh cool
you guys go drink whatever you want just
don't let us see it or whatever and that
would have been bad cuz eventually guess
what you put a bunch of seals on a ship
with with booze and you leave them on
there for multiple days at sea months at
sea well they're gonna have an incident
of some kind they're gonna get a fight
they're gonna throw up somewhere they're
gonna be you know just dumb stuff it's
gonna get to the highest level of
attention it's gonna be a totally this
kind of total disaster so the idea of
actually just stepping up and hold the
line and I'll tell you what I learned as
a leader is it's liberating to do that
it's liberating to say hey look here's
the rules and and you know I did this
with the fact of when we got back to
Ramadi when we got to Ramadi and they
told us we had to work with Iraqi
soldiers and everyone was kind of
hemming and hawing about having to work
with Iraqi soldiers and I told you guys
don't even submit a concept of
operations without Iraqi soldiers don't
even submit it because we're not doing
it and you guys were like okay got it
yeah
it is super liberating I think that's
the you know one of the things that that
I've you know that that I learned from
you as we sort of work together I mean
it and I talked about this all the time
I've talked about on the podcast before
but it was the kind of things that you
know you probably should be doing but
for whatever reason you art and and and
you know for you could just put in
perspective for me like it's very
black-and-white of like know if you're
not if you're not holding the line on
these things that are important and
pushing your team to perform at the
highest standard or making sure they're
not gonna do something it's gonna get
them in trouble or cause massive issues
not only for us but for the entire you
know not on for our unit but the entire
SEAL Teams then then that's you're
failing them as a leader you you've got
to hold the line on that stuff you've
got off and and it is very liberating to
say Oh check okay that's the way it is
no and and I think that ambiguity is
very frustrating for people that they
don't know what's right is wrong they
can get away with stuff yeah that's what
I was gonna say it's but the people
below you in the chain of command they
get frustrated because they're like what
was that mean and they're gonna push it
to the envelope that they
this guy got away with it over here but
that guy did yeah no I mean that's yeah
those are the kind of things where there
needs there's got to be a standard you
got to hold that standard and it's the
team is so much better off when you do
that and certainly bruiser absolutely
was and and this is one of those things
where then people think well Jocko
always holds the line and there'll be no
slack whatsoever right no fucking slack
right that's how we roll and it's like
mmm actually there is slack and there's
times where you give second I mean I
mean we I always talk about and we
always talk about how I was super strict
about uniforms right like hey we're
gonna wear uniforms no patches all this
stuff right we talk about this all the
time
but when someone was in when we were
when we were in our camp I didn't care
what you wore if you weren't gonna be
interacting with the army or the Marine
Corps I didn't care what you wore at all
I mean I barely put on a shirt we're all
a bit right I mean I'd be sitting in the
Tactical Operations Center let me tie up
fly flip-flops and shorts and a brown
t-shirt sometimes yeah sometimes and and
so I didn't I'm not holding the line I'm
not getting crazy cuz guess what that's
not important if I would have been
running around policing up people's
uniforms inside of our camp which was
just us man that would have wasted a
bunch of leadership capital and
frustrated everyone and then guess what
when I tell them hey you got to learn
how to program your radio that is that
is explained with the same importance as
hey you got a blouse your boots when
you're inside our camp that's the wrong
message to send so that's why this
that's why I wrote this book because
this is about balance you've got to be
able to balance when to hold the line
what's important what's worth holding
line for and what things do you go okay
you know what
you you know what life you guys want to
do it that way that's cool go do it and
that's what you need to learn that
balance that balance is hard it's hard
to do I think that again I think the
awareness of it I think the awareness of
it and I don't really know when I
recognize the awareness of it I'm gonna
know like when um when Flynn Flynn puts
up the slides of like the jock Aubry
from back in the day I talked about the
dichotomy leadership back then I'm
surprised I even knew what dichotomy
meant yeah if I looked at a right before
the briefing said what am I talking
about but it's one of those things I
recognized it I saw it and I could
definitely see it but now and this the
more we work with companies even when I
was in the teams the more I was working
with a seal platoon you'd see when a guy
was like here's a good example you know
when a guy talks too much when you have
a leader that just talks all the time
just doesn't stop he's always has
something else he he won't let anyone
else get the last word it's always that
guys the people stop listening to him
because he's talking all the time and
it's like hey I got a good idea why
don't you be quiet for a little while
and I I hated to have to tell that to
somebody because they get super
self-conscious but you know I'm usually
phrased in a different way like hey you
should you should you should let your
guys run a little bit you know let them
let them get the last word in let it's
gonna give them more ownership of what
you're doing if if when they get done
saying and that's how we're gonna do it
tonight
and then this guy chimes in and you know
what when we do it that way and you're
like you don't need to say it again he's
like you don't need to DoubleTap guys
would say that's debriefing I'm gonna
double tap that like that's already been
tapped
don't double tap it we're gonna triple
tap this thing we used to have a symbol
if you can't see this or you listen we
put our - whatever - peace signs and and
touch your thumbs together and it's like
four legs sticking up in the air that's
a dead horse that's the symbol for dead
horse bro you don't need to say this
again it's a dead horse quit beating it
to death wait what does double what it's
double tap DoubleTap well when you shoot
a target you shoot it once and then what
you normally do is you shoot it twice
boom boom and so it's called a double
tap let's go that fast multiple so if I
was a briefing you and and I was like
echo you know you need to keep your shot
groups a little bit tighter on the next
run cool you got it that's it well the
DoubleTap on that you know you really
need to work on the shot yeah I'm saying
the same thing kind of like I second
that notion it kind of thing it is but
if you said that if you said I second
that you could leave it there right but
if you said I second that
the
you really need to tighten up your
groups because my groups or a little bit
dispersed around the target area and
that's gonna be bad we all know it's bad
bro think think office space TPS report
never sink clear now and now all that
being said so it's cool I think again
having the combat stories let some of
these things and that's a good example
right there you're talking first person
what you're actually thinking which i
think is powerful but it's good also to
to outline the principles and then
that's what we did so here's one of the
principles we outlined and this is an
important one because man we got because
we talk about being aggressive as a
matter of fact we have t-shirts that say
default aggressive right like we're not
playing around being aggressive and what
does that mean that means that we get
some people in this in the military and
in the civilian sector that we say
default mode aggressive they go default
mode aggressive and they don't know when
to stop they get reckless they get
careless they go too hard and so going
back to the book here problems aren't
going to solve themselves a leader must
get aggressive and take action to solve
the problems and implement a solution
being too passive and waiting for a
solution to appear often enables the
problem to escalate and get out of
control the enemy isn't going to back
off the leader must get aggressive and
put the enemy in check the good deal
isn't going to deliver itself to a
company the leader has to go out and
make a good deal happen changes and new
methodologies in a team aren't going to
implement themselves leaders need to
aggressively implement them an
aggressive mindset should be the default
setting of any leader default aggressive
this means that the best leaders the
best teams don't wait to act instead
understanding the strategic vision or
commander's intent they aggressively
execute to overcome obstacles capitalize
on immediate opportunities accomplish
the mission and win
rather than passively waiting to be told
what to do default aggressive leaders
proactively seek out ways to further the
strategic mission they understand the
commander's intent and where they have
authority to do so they execute for
decisions that are beyond their pay
grade or above their authority default
aggressive leaders still make a
recommendation up the chain of command
to solve problems and execute key tasks
to achieve strategic victory in seal
platoons and task units we expect this
from leaders at every level right down
to the front line trooper in charge of
just himself and his small piece of the
mission but this mentality is crucial to
any leader in any team or organization
it is just as critical to success in
business as on the battlefield
aggressive means proactive but it
doesn't mean that leaders can get angry
lose their temper or be aggressive
toward their people a leader must always
deal professionally with subordinates on
the team peers leaders up the chain of
command customers or clients and
personnel and supporting roles outside
the immediate team speaking angrily to
others is ineffective losing your temper
is a sign of weakness
the aggression that wins on the
battlefield in business or in life is
directed not toward people but towards
solving problems achieving goals and
accomplishing the mission it is also
critical to balance aggression with
careful thought and analysis to make
sure that risks have been assessed and
mitigated the dichotomy with the default
aggressive mindset is that sometimes
hesitation allows a leader to further
understand a situation so that he or she
can react properly to it rather than
immediately respond to enemy fire
sometimes the prudent decision is to
wait and see how it develops is it a
simple reconnaissance by fire is it a
feint by the enemy meant
distract from the real attack is the
enemy simply trying to lure you into a
confined area where they have a superior
force waiting to ambush a careful moment
of consideration might reveal the
enemy's true intentions to be overly
aggressive without critical thinking is
to be reckless that can lead the team
into a disaster and put the greater
mission in peril to disregard prudent
counsel when someone with experience
urges caution to dismiss significant
threats or to fail to plan for likely
contingencies is foolhardy it is bad
leadership a chief contributing factor
to recklessness comes from what military
historians have long referred to as the
disease of victory this disease takes
place when a few battlefield successes
produce an overconfidence in a team's
own tactical prowess while under
estimating the capabilities of its enemy
or competitor this is a problem not just
for combat leaders but for leaders and
teams anywhere in any arena throughout
the business world and the civilian
sector it is a leaders duty to fight
against this disease so that the team
despite its success never gets
complacent the risk in any action must
be carefully weighed against the
potential rewards of mission success and
of course to counter that thought the
cost of inaction must be weighed as well
as aggressive as leaders must be leaders
must be cautious that they are not
running to their deaths simply because
it is their instinct to take action the
dichotomy between aggression and caution
must be balanced so be aggressive but
never reckless
so there's a principle the principle
laid out and then of course it's
followed up with a business example of
which there are manifold of of
businesses where the business gets too
aggressive they start gaining properties
to put more stores into and they build
up all this rent that they gotta pay
every month the next thing you know they
have a down month and they got real
estate bills to pay or they start hiring
a ton of people because they get a super
aggressive in that's you know kind of
where this story leads to is what break
gonna bring in all these people because
we think this future success is coming
and the next thing you know your
overhead is so huge because you got
overly aggressive you end up with
problems that that is hard to that's so
hard because it that is absolutely in my
nature is to and I think in into and so
many people that resonate with extreme
ownership that come to the musters that
I mean we've got default aggressive
leaders that want to go dominate the
universe and you've got to really you've
got to really take a step back and
detach and think okay what am I not
thinking about what am I not seeing how
am i planning for those contingencies we
just talked about you know situation
today you know with with a client where
you know they when things are going
really well right that's when you gotta
be looking at okay would what what's
what's what's about to go wrong that I
haven't seen yet you know what am I not
playing it for so it is very very
difficult to balance this as a leader
but you absolutely have to balance it
you have to be aggressive you have to
maneuver you know so many people get you
know the the paralysis to analysis that
people talk about don't want to make it
make a decision until you know the
solution is right there and it's a
hundred percent guaranteed nothing is
ever 100% guaranteed and by the time
that's that you know that's even close
to being that you know the competition's
already maneuvered on the battlefield
out killed you know in the business
world you know you're gonna get you're
gonna get crushed by your competition
and and so and yet being aggressive and
also being prudent so that you're not
falling in the traps not running to your
desk not setting your team up for total
disaster and it's it's the only the only
answer to this the only answer to this
is you have to be balanced that's the
only answer because if you go too far in
one direction the other if you get super
aggressive and you take too much risk
and you'll get wiped out if you
don't do anything and you sit there
you're gonna get wiped out you have to
you have to balance these two all the
time and yeah you're right this is
something that it's something that we
see all the time and I saw it you know
training Co platoons you get the guy
that's super hyper aggressive and every
time there's something going on there a
let's send a fire team over there and
okay you send you send a fire team over
there and then that fire team gets
whacked I'll send another five team over
there okay then that fire team gets
Michael send another fire team next
thing you know you'll have a platoon
left okay so that was good you got
everyone killed because you were hyper
aggressive the other end of the spectrum
is well we're not sure where the fires
coming from so we're gonna sit here and
wait okay well while you're not shooting
at the enemy the enemy is maneuvering
and they are getting high ground and
they are getting a superior position and
this is the exact same thing in the
business world where I mean the example
of like hey we got to grow and so the
aggressive leader the overly aggressive
the hyper aggressive leader will grow
too fast and all of a sudden has
overhead that's too much and can't
afford to go on but at the same time you
get a you get a company that's not
that's not aggressive enough and they
should be entering another another line
of operation they should be putting they
should be entering another market you
know we were talking about this morning
while we were working out block
blockbuster and Blackberry right
blockbuster and blackberry who would
have thought that blockbuster which was
there was a blockbuster on every street
corner and there was a block blackberry
in everyone's pocket and they owned
something like 80 something percent of
the market share that they're done now
are you telling me that someone that was
default aggressive would have said you
know what we need to figure out how to
you know what these these movies might
be able to come on the Internet in fact
there's streaming video let's get into
that market and of course they would
have had the capital they would have had
the infrastructure they would have had
the people and and they could have they
would have been been able to make that
happen
they had relationships with with the
with the big Hollywood studios right
they were getting sent those movies they
had relationships they could have done
that but they were sitting there going
you're gonna come rent these videos for
$4.99
you got to get that VHS tape up in here
right that's the way it's got to be and
same thing with blackberry there think
all no one's gonna leave us because we
got the little thing with the keyboard
on it and we're set and and meanwhile
they're both done done lack of
aggressive lack of foresight lack of
planning and and for me it's really just
lack of being aggressive aggressively
looking around now we could go the other
way and we could look at look at
companies that put so much capital out
there that they run out of money and
they go they go down too so what do you
have to do you have to balance you have
to balance that's what you have to do uh
you know one more thing I think we do
one more thing from this from this book
just you and it's a short short little
piece we were talking about earlier and
it kind of relates to what and then I
think the reason we were talking about
cuz it was kind of related in the
disease effector II you had that little
chunk again we do that we do the
applications of business so people can
see really directly how these principles
in combat and the principle correlates
to the civilian sector but you had a
good one just couple paragraphs on 84
about your kind of a stereotypical fired
up extreme ownership boss that's gonna
call them in there and make stuff happen
I thought this was a good one go I've
read a lot about Patton the executive
vice president said with pride referring
to General George S Patton jr. the
famous US Army General whose exploits in
World War two were legendary I love that
you reference Patton in your
presentation I want exactly the kind of
discipline organization around here that
Patton expected we need people who carry
out orders not question them I could
tell right away that the executive vice
president had no previous military
experience
he clearly misunderstood how effective
leaders in the military led their teams
it was not through rigid
authoritarianism do this because I said
so or you'll be punished sure there were
those in the military who tried to lead
like that but it was never effective so
there you go and I know you and I both
and
the team has dealt with guys that they
have that vision of this military
leadership and usually it's guys don't
want the military and you know I like to
draw a line and maybe I'm right maybe
I'm wrong about this I think well and
and from what I know from military
history when you go back to conscripts
when you when you get to the conscripts
those guys are beaten until they are
doing what they you know what they're
told to do we've we've covered some
great examples of that on this podcast
of situations where it's Ike oh you know
what you know how we're gonna lead we're
gonna lead through tyranny and we're
gonna lead through punishment and we're
gonna lead through rigid discipline
rigid discipline which obviously
everyone knows I'm a fan of discipline
but when you're leading guys and the
reason that they're following your
orders is because they fear being beaten
or fear being shot that shot by you you
know
punished by you if that's why there
again it's the same situation where if
that's why they're doing it you're never
gonna get the true optimal work and
effort out of those people ever and even
from from history I mean if you read
Alexander the Great right or or Julius
Caesar who's a great example you know
they had conscripts but his men loved
him and admired him and held him in
tremendous regard conceived he rewarded
them he gave them credit he he explained
well hi um and he was he was a guy who
was always put himself for the forefront
of of where the fighting was and you
know much more so than just a political
leader like many of the Roman the Roman
leaders so just a phenomenal leader on
the battlefield and so even even then
you're the most effective leaders are
always going to be they're always going
to try to get the team on board with a
mission help them understand why they're
doing it put it put a greater purpose in
their mind and I think so often as you
said before you know leader a leader
like that this was this was an
aggressive leader great you know great
person who wanted to dominate the
universe and and make these happen love
extreme ownership and yet is is
struggling to see that because they
think they're leading like you would
leave they look at they look at a
picture of Jocko like this is what Jocko
into it's just crush everyone and tell
them to do it because I said and as
you've explained it doesn't work it
doesn't work that way
it's
never effective and that's why that's
why I'm I'm proud of this book and I
think you can be so useful to leaders to
see you can't do that if you do that
you're not ever gonna be as successful
as you could be if you actually get the
team on board explain why to them and
and and tie that to the bigger purpose
of what you're trying to accomplish in
the world yeah yeah I think that's all
true I think the book will be helpful to
people so yeah dichotomy leadership it's
coming out September 25th and you want
to if you want to get some you can get
some of that we got some Q&A we've got
some questions to discuss here I'll just
jump right into it number one what are
speaking of that this is this is phone
together quite nicely question number
one what are things to look for when
you're debating whether to raise your
voice or yell do to those under you
being lazy or unmotivated you all talk a
lot about the importance of self-control
and not just losing it but would you say
there's a time and place for raising the
intensity while still being respectful
towards your guys so there you go
yelling and screaming get some sometimes
you got to just drop the hammer
Jaakko yelled and scream at us all the
time like I've talked about on this you
know I think on the podcast we certainly
talk about all the time I mean the
number of times that Jaakko screamed and
yelled at me zero zero times in all the
years that we work together and I know I
gave him at least dozens maybe hundreds
of opportunities they want to probably
done that and he didn't do that because
he realized it wasn't effective
so now listen there there is there is a
time where you know if there's a major
safety issue going on and you're trying
to get people's attention and you want
people a ceasefire or you need to rally
the troops where you got to raise your
voice and get people's attention and I
think that's you can't be afraid to do
that as well there are certainly times
rights a life get those probably signed
up over there or stuff like that I mean
for sure that's is that yelling well
yeah I'm definitely raising my voice and
using a loud voice but I'm not doing it
whatever with anger it's just hey you
got to hear me and so and also you know
there is times where you've got a
to pick up the intensity in your voice
so that people realize there's something
important happening right there's just
enough now you don't want to yell and
scream and get all crazy but to be like
hey I need vehicles here now like that
is different than hey can you get the
vehicles over here now right those are
two different things and you I would
react differently if I heard those two
voices so yes now to go over you now no
one now we're creating a whole panic
situation but that's a great point too
right and it's it's the kind of you know
never cry wolf you know so when you're
if you're yelling all the time how do
you do this vehicles over here right now
when there's nothing at stake and it's
no big deal and it's just a routine
movement you know then when you do that
and you really need it then no one's
paying attention that they go it's just
life yelling again into the radio so so
I think that's another reason why I
actually have seen Jocko raise his voice
on one occasion yeah yeah and when there
was a serious issue that needed to be
addressed and you needed to get the
person's attention to show just how
serious of a situation it was and it got
everybody's attention it got everybody's
attention right away because you never
did that and when you did do it it was
like oh man yeah and I was always tell
that to leaders like being on the radio
and this good goes for being in a
meeting right if you go to a meeting if
you're in charge of a meeting and you
talk the whole time and then you have
something important to the to say at the
end well that's great but it's not as
impactful as when you say very few
things during the meeting and then at
the end you say hey guys listen up
here's what's going along with this and
everyone everyone pays attention so I've
said this before the less you talk the
more people listen and that goes true
here the more you yell the less people
listen and it takes away the opportunity
if you ever do have to yell it's gonna
have zero impact so my blanket statement
is you should hardly ever have to raise
your voice and you should just barely
ever happen next question
it's a long one can you explain more how
you managed working with the local Iraqi
troops general mattis who I hold in the
highest esteem esteem said something to
the effect that if you are doing
anything that negatively impacts
relations with Allied forces you are of
more use to the enemy than you are to
the your team this makes it quite
obvious that he believes that full
cooperation with Allied forces is key to
attaining victory it is a
well-established fact that most of the
Iraqi forces were incompetent to the
point of posing danger to US troops so
what steps did you take to ensure
success when working with them well
obviously relations with your allies are
critical if it's cover move phred you
gotta work together as a team and and if
you've got if you're working against
each other that's absolutely
catastrophic I I think for us with Iraqi
troops you know again we talked about
how that was liberating right for you
know the big pushback was always like is
we want to do just seal unilateral
operation we call just seals or just
Americans you know just like NATO ally
forces and and not work with with Iraqi
troops and you know when you said that
ran away and asking because listen don't
even put up a concept of operation -
pretty fuckin ops we call it which is
the approval for the plan that doesn't
have Iraqi troops on it okay got it
we're gonna have to figure out a way to
make that happen so that was the line
was drawn we knew we had to do that and
we knew it was also important I mean
because you explaining that we talked
about it we we thought through that but
obviously we had to take some steps to
mitigate that so I think there were
there were again this is the dichotomy
it's you got to be balanced they were I
saw units who thought and we gave some
examples even extreme ownership
certainly and we talked about regularly
about where you see a unit that would
take two or four Americans and a bunch
of Iraqis and try to go in a really bad
area you're like man you know you're not
gonna be able to count on those Iraqis
in the middle of a gunfight when they're
overwhelmed you better have enough
Americans here to have your back so so
they were asking too much of the Iraqis
and then their other units didn't want
to do you know didn't want
many Iraqis wear them didn't have any
relationships with them and I had some
stern talking-to
you know stop talking soon so my guys
who wouldn't weren't treating Iraqi
soldiers with respect I threatened one
of my guys who's gonna have to go sleep
in Iraqi soldiers barracks if you didn't
shake their hand I think he you know
individual who's a great guy I think
that was the last threat you had to make
him to make him submit I think I was
serious the president like I'm totally
serious
so props to props the SF guys mid teams
that go out there and they do they live
they eat you know even even haven't
Dakota Meyer in here he did two meals a
day out of three with with his Afghan
soldiers that's that's awesome and you
know what I liked about this question
was the way that that it relates to to
the civilian sector because you know
what I talk about a lot a lot of times I
talk about how my relationship with my
boss regardless of who my boss was
regardless of my boss was great or my
boss was horrible
my relationship was always the same I
was gonna have this great I was gonna
build relationship where they trusted me
they gave me what I needed to do my job
and then they let me do my job that's
the relationship I always had with all
my bosses right but I that same
methodology and concept can absolutely
be applied to other organizations that
you're supposed to work with so whether
it's the army whether it's the Marine
Corps whether it's the Iraqi soldiers
whether it's the MPs whether it's the I
the the Intel people who that the Intel
organization that you're working with no
matter what the organization you can
build a relationship again might you
love that organization no you might not
and where I see this all the time well
we see it all the time now is with
businesses because guess what there's no
business that standalone or I should say
there's very few that are completely
vertically integrated businesses I mean
like an origin right we don't we were
pretty vertically integrated but guess
what we don't grow the cotton like we
don't do that we don't grow cotton but
guess what we have a good relationship
with the people that grow cotton we have
a good relationship with the people that
stain the continent or sorry die the
cotton so we build those relationships
with those other people now I work with
businesses where there's a supplier that
they don't like
so guess what they form a hostile
relationship with this whole company a
whole company what good does that do
them it doesn't do them any good at all
what it means is they have no personal
relationships they form that
antagonistic relationship with a whole
nother organization and it's almost
impossible to overcome so now this is
something where if you don't explain
that culture throughout your team
they're gonna treat that other team
horribly and so if you're waiting on
supplies if you're on a construction
site and you're waiting for materials to
be delivered and you don't have a good
relationship with the people that
deliver the drywall and now the drywall
is running late for whatever reason and
you call look you you fly off the handle
or whatever you're you're not gonna get
that drywall any earlier it's not
happening have you ever you know when I
call customer service right customer
servile honest when I was working for
that for the Admiral working from the
Admirals aide I'd call up Whedon we
traveled a lot and I'd have to call up
whatever Delta or American whoever and
I'd be trying to get whatever seats on
an aircraft or something or a flight
that was for whatever getting him an
upgrade whatever and you know I'd say
hey how you doing that's always I always
start off with the wig cuz they're gone
American airline how can I help you and
they're mad right they're just mad to
start with I'd give how to date they're
mad whatever you know airline whatever
red car rental service whatever
restaurant with like people are just mad
they don't care they're bad they don't
know who you are well they actually
they've just talked to probably you know
the last 25 people have screamed and
screamed and yell at him and it's awful
so you know you you call him and say hey
how's it going and you know I always I
had little had little micro jokes that I
would make with the airlines that I used
them with all of them all the time
but one of them was I'd say they table
do you need to do you need to sit next
to your boss and I'd say you know what
I'd honestly appreciate it if you put me
as far away from it and they'd laugh and
then they'd try and hook me up or even
though my boss was a great guy and I'd
sit with him all day but just it was a
funny thing and it it humanized me with
them they thought I was benched some
poor sorry bastard that had to travel
with his boss and then they were trying
to take care of me
it was like awesome so I would get the
hookups I remember one time I went up
and I had a conversation on the phone
with someone and then of course this is
different cuz it was live but I had a
conversation like now can't get you on
that flight and then I went up to the
counter and I was like hey how you doing
I'm trying to get me at my boss and it's
on this flight and we're trying to get
there and he's a girl's like well you
know do you need to go to them like well
look if we don't get there here's the
deal if you can just get my boss on
that's great if if neither one of us
could get on this flight it's been nice
knowing you
cuz I'm screwed and she just started
laughing and again humanized it and then
it's like all sudden she's like Oh guess
what we can we're gonna pump some of
these or whatever and she's making Roman
we're on the flight so don't develop
this antagonistic relationship with
another organization with Iraqi soldiers
like is it great working with Iraqi
soldiers no it sucks it's hard but guess
what that's what we have to do and I'll
tell you something else
strategically the Iraqi soldiers that
are descendants of the guys that we
trained to me maybe not I'm saying
training or training descendents right
the guys that we trained trained guys
who just went and fought back and got
Ramadi back from Isis and got Missoula
back from Isis those are the guys that
went in there and did the bulk the
fighting did they get supported by
Americans yes did Americans do a
kick-ass job of doing massive fire
support yes but the guys that were
moving from Street to Street
those were majority Iraqi soldiers did
they have special ops guys with him yes
but it was a majority of the people that
were moving through the streets we're
Iraqi soldiers and there's no way
possible that wouldn't have happened if
American coalition forces over the last
for whatever it was 10 years 12 years
would have taken those guys and made
them work and done the the type of
partner missions that we did with him so
it was and when I say again when I say
we am I talking about us the the SEAL
Teams I'm talking about everyone
everyone made this concerted effort and
it ended up being a great call because
when those guys went out to to finally
have to fight to take these cities back
they were able to do it not totally by
themselves but they were able to do it
they did it and that's a vast
if we would have sent if we would have
sent the Iraqi troops as they were when
we were in Ramadi into Missoula
they would have gotten decimated so it's
a credit to the US military it's a
credit to the Iraqi military that they
have now gotten up to speed where they
can push forward and to credit the US
military and other coalition forces that
work with them to get them up to speed
and what that all boils back to is
forming relationships with the people
that you are dependent on not just the
people but the organizations that's all
I'm saying yeah I think they we learned
a lesson it's it's let's do let's use
them for their strengths and and that's
what we learned in Ramadi we put them in
situations where they could succeed we
took enough Americans where we could
actually succeed and and and help them
succeed and and of course we put some
you know some efforts to mitigate rs.2
with with all we always had armed guys
you had guys looking around we always
would presented a you know hard target
if one of those guys decided that they
wanted to you know start batting for the
other team and you know we were in a
position to handle those problems and we
never had any issues as a result but
that's that's what you have to do is
it's all about building coalitions and
and and using people's strengths and
complementing those strengths and
working as a team it's it's cover move
if you don't do that you're gonna you're
gonna fail yeah and to all you people at
the airlines thank you
thank you for taking care of me over the
years appreciate it next question Jocko
Lafe and echo
your opinion has been solicited on this
leadership question right here so we'll
see how that works out
a good leader ensures his team
understands what their goals are and why
there are performing tasks but how do
you balance doing this with not being
the leader that talks so much that the
team stops listening we do we just cover
this for a long period of time pretty
much it didn't we I guess we can leave
it at this echo do you agree with what
we said earlier or do you have a
different opinion about talking too much
and mind you you've set a lot today so
don't be you know don't get up don't get
crazy over there or we'll stop listening
mm-hmm the guy who talks too much no
yeah less is more hundred percent agree
there you go I like it I will say it
musters when echoes echoes words to the
audience Yoga is an epic speech with we
have solicited probably the greatest
applause of everyone out there yeah men
see I guess to dig in this a little bit
of how to balance that with with being a
leader that talks so much I think you've
got to pay attention to what the
reactions are you're getting from people
right you've got to pay attention to the
reactions you're getting from people if
the people are not totally actively
listening to you right if they're not
actively listening to you if they're
taking notes if they're looking at their
phone or what I'm not taking notes but
if they're looking at their phone or
whatever then you're you're talking too
much keep it short keep it concise and
people will listen to you more also that
um when you say you got to pay attention
to yourself that's like a deep one it's
like you just said it really simply like
I say just pay attention to yourself I
mean you didn't say it like that but
that's what it felt like that's the
hardest part right there because a lot
of times like hey meanne life for
talking and lace starts looking at his
phone I'm not thinking hey I'm talking
too much I'm saying what I'm saying it's
not interesting enough so I need so I
need to say some more cool stuff or I
need to be more this or more of that
because I'm losing them kind of thing
like if I'm losing you
the intuitive thought is not to to
completely disconnect and stop talking
that's not the intuitive thought seems
like when you're in a situation
gotta pay attention to that kind stuff
on yourself Jocko does this all the time
bosses phone out and starts you know
what okay go
I guess their conversations you know you
know I do that Dean and Dean mister so
Dean Dean Jack this is really important
stuff we're talking about areas like ya
know what Dean does so is he it makes
him mad right he's got the he's got the
pet peeve so Dean will be telling say
something and so you're doing on purpose
to get a new schism no sometimes he's
saying some rambling stuff right and I'm
I got stuff going on Dean come on I know
you're listening to this bro but
sometimes he'll be saying something to
me and all of a sudden I'll like all
like look around all but and and now I
realize I'll just be watching people do
jujitsu cuz we're normally on the mat
well this happens so he's telling me
something like look at me the eyes and
he's like you know in the ancient
ba-ba-ba-ba
here we telling me about the
Peloponnesian War or something or
whatever and and as I'm listening to him
I'll kind of look and I'll just like
start looking at someone that's training
or look at something and he'll he'll
like attack me he went through a period
where he would just attack me
and like take me down and just start you
know going psycho on me so that got me
tuned up
I got me tuned up when I try and give
Dean some more attention yeah I like
that
yeah yeah I think that's uh I think it's
a good feel like when he starts doing
that surprise see what you're doing well
the thing is though and I think you're
in the same boat life where I know you
kind of know now like I in everyday life
with other people you might think I mean
intuitively anyway like oh I'm losing
him or whatever but you tell with him if
he starts doing that stuff you're like
okay and he's no stop or yeah I move on
or something but if you give me thirty
five more seconds I will say that's a
bad characteristic that I have where I
can do that sometimes I'm done listening
to you
so wrap it up efficiency all the time
yeah time management system all right
next question
for Lafe this is going everyone you know
what
all right life in an out burger or
Whataburger dude I do not want to go
there man that is that is too much
that's like double rainbow too much man
this is uh I'm gonna tell you it look
obviously I'm from Texas water burgers
are all over the place and water burgers
are awesome you can't go wrong with
water burger in and out is uh it's
pretty tough to beat though it's there's
something special about the end and I
used to have you know over in Pacific
Beach
I had a storage unit over there and
there's like my storage unit was like
riding in an Upper Hill those are good
burgers dude the my steward unit was it
would like kick the exhaust wreck right
back up into the so it's so like the
exhausting in your face you know from
like 25 yards 30 yards away yeah as I'm
like they're my storage unit unloading
surfboards or whatever knows like double
double we're getting some Java no more
so yeah in announcer awesome like it's
it's tough to beat I'm a huge fan in and
out I will say this though where's the
meat man
come on those burgers you got to put
what a burger
you got a lot more more patty Jim well
apparently you're not working the triple
triple quadruple quadruple my my kids
after they would cut weight for
wrestling during wrestling season I
spent more money in an Out Burger during
wrestling season cuz after they cut
weight and then they wrestle all day and
then you're going home and all they want
to do is get out
in-n-out burger in-and-out burger yeah
it's it cutting weight from is very I
mean playing football is like man you
want to be as big and fast as well as me
convinces crush food yeah all right
speaking of well I guess speaking of
combat sports next question six this is
a jujitsu question should instructors
not teach white belts aka Lafe Bob and
David Burke and JP Danelle that's
cold-blooded
a good deal t that is good deal Dave
should instructors not teach white belts
certain techniques or should why they
shouldn't do them be explained but still
expose the white belts to techniques so
that the white belts recognize it so
there's some techniques that you don't
get taught very often as a white belt
for instance a heel look I believe that
it is good to not teach people teach
white belts to do heel hooks because
that for example heel hooks can be very
dangerous the reason that they're
dangerous is because they don't hurt a
lot before they injure you and so white
belts who are by nature completely
insane and going crazy and going nuts
and so when they get ahold of something
they just go as hard as they can and by
the way they're usually going against
the white belt that's the only reason
they're getting anything on them it's
growing against white belt and that
other white belts going completely
insane and he's not gonna tap and so
what happens you get the triple triple
lindy right ACL MCL PCL tear game over
this guy's never trained in jiu-jitsu
again or this guy's not trained in
jiu-jitsu for two years or whatever so
is it smart to not teach them yes it is
however dichotomy balance should you
just never show them what they are no
you should you should explain to them
hey this is what the move is this is
this is why we don't teach them the
other thing this is why we don't teach
them because you can get hurt and when
you get a little bit more advanced and
you learn to relax a little more we'll
teach you some of these mmm these
techniques that are slightly more
dangerous Dean always freaks out because
you saying that a heel hook is more
dangerous than than a Chimaera I mean if
you ask me whether I want to have
somebody just go berserk on a cousin
Chimaera on me or a heel hook I'd
probably pick the heel hook right
because then you you still have shoulder
mobility
whereas Chimaera that's that's just if
someone goes nuts on a camera and just
rips your arm your shoulder apart would
you rather have the hook for sure yeah
I'm thinking all day long so but for
some reason it's a kind of a rough
choice there that is rough choice that
is the rapture
that's not a choice you want to be
making because either one of them's not
good but I think you can do a better job
of replacing the knee and getting them
nice squared away then you can the
shoulder there's no the shoulders tough
but for some reason the commuters
everyone you're learning come here at
day one right
day three you're learning camera and you
could definitely trash someone's
shoulder but it hurts it does hurt then
that's beneficial yeah any the chills
gonna have way more flexibility than
your your knee twisting joint you like
that say you can't be like hey unless
you get some joke so you got guys who
can be shoulder you know there's varying
levels of shoulder flexibility and then
that also goes for like the pain
tolerance as well knee is less
weightless from from a white Bell
perspective oh there's so much to learn
I mean it's it yeah and the more I tried
the more I realized how little I
actually know and how much more there is
that I mean why I would I would rather
focus on you know on the more the more
foundational aspects of the game and
until I can get those a little bit
better I think yes that makes a lot of
sense to me I think you might be the
bull white belt right now off the world
so in the in the Navy the ensign which
is the lowest ranking ensign at a ship
or a SEAL team he gets called the bull
ensign which means he's been the junior
guy for the longest amount of time yeah
and you've been trained for the white
stuff would you you go you start talking
with me in 2005 right yeah didn't you
train before me with Fabio clattering a
few times have okay so you've been
training since oh three oh four it's
been a long time most of that sort years
most of that 14 years I'd say I've been
seriously training for you know probably
probably like back at it you know pretty
consistently you know mobile times a
week for a year and a half okay so your
zero zone you're in the zone you'd be
getting that boot about you at some
point Todd white down in Texas gonna
crack it out possibly I don't know maybe
you're not ready you know I make John
white I'm definitely not ready he's
going No
you got nothing you got nothing check
so yeah that's I think the deal same
thing with same thing the other problem
with teaching a person for instance heel
hooks is then they think that that's the
solution to the guard and it's not the
solution to the guard
it's a solution to the garden it's one
possible one one one small possible on a
solution there's many many more and
there's others as you said leaf that are
more fundamental so it's that's my
that's my answer
yeah that thing um how you say that like
let them know what it is yeah and when
you consider an actual typical white
belt class the hill could probably not
going to be introduced in any
significant capacity yeah at all like no
one's gonna choose to spend time in a
way that the white belt class to teach a
hill it typically does not happen but
like the control thing right like you
know you get even a good blue belt who's
been in for a long time purple belt and
up they're gonna know the control and a
heel hook like if I you know a purple
belt doesn't he look on you the risk of
you getting injured unless you don't tap
or something like that is pretty low so
gonna be pretty low because they know
that control of just their whole body
and I don't know you should tap exactly
right yes so the white belt they don't
even have contribute very important they
don't know control or they have a lot
less control in everything by the way
the strong possibility but that's with
everything like even on a defending a
takedown or defendant it's like so Auto
Chi as a blue belt I heal hooked a
friend of mine and I heard him and and I
didn't it wasn't even he was he was a he
was in know nothing right and we're
going and I just started learning heel
hooks and I put a heel hook on him and
we were overseas and I put a heel hook
on him and he wasn't tapping and I was
kind of like oh that's weird
you know why isn't he tapping so I went
a little bit harder and then all of a
sudden there was a little pop and I let
going I was like and yeah but you know
he was a seal and so he was like all
this is gonna work on me it doesn't hurt
her feel it so I I wasn't going nuts
because I like I said I was a blue belt
I was in pretty good control but
even I didn't realize at that time oh
this will injure him before it will
cause pain which is a bad thing to have
yeah so yeah these kids I mean these
guys if they're no one has control over
anything by the way any any of their
moves and they're doing heel hooks as a
normal thing like oh yeah we got taught
this and stuff and it's effective you
know like a lot of submissions and he
looks and a lot of foot locks or one of
those ones worried you to gain the
position to go for that submission you
have to work a lot less than like an
armbar where you have to actually pass
someone's guard and you know getting
even side control but a lot of times get
to them you know you got to work more to
get into the position with you hooks not
not so much like that so if you know
throw it Adam yeah you can just throw it
out there and you throw in the lack of
control yeah man so you increase the
chance for injury for sure all right
next question
I am a 66 year old police chief and
CrossFit athlete is your muster doable
for me absolutely yeah you'll be they'll
be plenty of people who are in your age
group and there's no question that you
should come and join us for muster get
after if you're your police chief your
CrossFit athlete you can more more than
get after with this the 445 Club
workouts are voluntary
we usually have I mean we probably have
what you know 80 85 percent
participation I mean is massive but
they're designed so that really anybody
can do it we have people with top level
athletes down to you know folks who look
like the pride and been in the gym a
whole lot we had a fresh start again so
I remember one guy that was I'm heading
in for doubled knee surgery in a week
and so I'm just he was an older guy you
know that had been out of the gym for a
bit and he was out there like you said
that the the workouts are scalable to
the individual that's participating in
the in the events and so we at all every
level you can come to muster in any
literally in any physical condition you
can come to the muster and you can you
can get after it with us next question I
find meetings
of greater than or equal to eight people
far less productive than smaller groups
even with with a structured
action-oriented agenda is there a
maximum amount of people you'd involve
in a strategic or tactical planning
group I don't think I don't think there
is a maximum at I think it just has to
be controlled and you've got to have
you've got to have some decentralized
man or people understand if there's just
a bunch of people to meeting and
everyone's kind of speaking in in turn
and talking over each other you're not
gonna get anything done so you gotta
have there's got to be one leader who's
running that there's got to be some some
you know some other subordinate leaders
that and and one person has got to drive
that meeting and make sure that when
someone starts going in down a rabbit
hole okay you guys have a sidebar
conversation afterward let's keep this
meeting focused and let's and ultimately
that a decision-maker who can focus the
team on a single course of action get
her by behind them the eye I agree and
there's certainly times where you can
bring too many people in to try and
figure something out I mean that can
certainly happen and we we have the good
idea of fairies that keep coming around
with their good ideas and because I
don't know what if he did someone if we
did that there's also an interesting
dynamic that you just pointed out that
ties into a question that we had earlier
or something that we were talking about
earlier which is okay so let's say we
have a meeting and there's 15 people in
that meeting if the leader of that
meeting then we'll say steps down into
the position of being the the director
of the meeting itself guess what he's
doing the whole time he's talking he's
pulling things he's getting and what
he's doing while he's doing that is he's
getting in the weeds of what's going on
so as he's getting in the weeds of
what's going on
he's losing this strategic vision and so
if there's 20 people in a meeting and
you as the leader are going okay what do
you think what do you think what are you
thinking hey no let's get it felt
refocused when you're doing all that
traffic copping you're actually losing
your strategic altitude you're not going
to be able to see and make a good clear
decision so if there's 30 40 50 people
in a meeting and you as the leader get
down
in the weeds and get down in the
trenches and you start throwing down
with everyone well it's not gonna take
very long well you're just you're just
one of the troops and you don't see
anything whereas if you let let one of
the other leaders let one of the
supportive leaders let them step up let
them start to do their thing let them do
the direction of meaning you might even
tell them hey run this meeting I would
do that I'd be like hey you run this
meeting and then you let them get in
there in the trenches and let them try
and sort out ideas make their mind gets
filled with a bunch of crap and
meanwhile you're in the meeting you're
just not running it so there's a big
difference between running the meeting
and overseeing the meeting or being in
the meeting or being a leading leader of
a meeting so if we're going through a
kill house or if we're going if we're
going through a kill house that's a good
example which is you know the room with
the building with a bunch of rooms in it
if as the leader you don't say hey I'm
gonna run this kill house I'm not gonna
I'm not I'm not gonna direct the
movement through the kill house cuz then
guess what you're doing you're directing
the movement through the kill house what
you want to do is take a step back and
say hey you third fourth fifth and the
chain of command
you run this kill house you run the
train and now that guy goes okay cool I
got it and now while he's running the
train doing the work your step back at
altitude you can see what's going on you
can hear the frustration you can hear
shots fire do you know what people are
moving then you become your the real
leader so same thing at a meeting the
dynamics of the meeting or you get more
than 10 people 15 people and what you're
doing is you're down there directing
traffic it's gonna be really problematic
for you if you have a meeting with 15 or
20 people and you tell someone else to
direct the meeting and run the meeting
and you take a step up and you simply
observe you're gonna have a better time
feeling like the meeting is effective
and you will get the benefit of hearing
all these different voices which is good
which is good to hear all these
different opinions and voices and be
able to pick through and sort through
and that's going to give you more
benefit than you know what I get there's
too much going on in this meeting only
give me two people and we'll make the
decisions well there's some people
number of number the the sixth person
that person had a good input right the
12th person might have some good input
so again is there balance yes are there
certain decisions that you kind of need
to take and really dive down in with a
small group absolutely but is it good
sometimes to let things air out and let
someone run a meeting and you listen and
you learn kind of what the overall
atmospherics of the situation are
absolutely that's my answer I think it's
a great but it helps people it helps me
to listen to you as well right I mean
when if if you're the boss and you're
just sitting back and you're not say
anything and then all of a sudden you're
like hey guys we're getting way off
topic here this is what we need to do
here's the direction we need to go got
it everyone's you know back on track
whereas if you're in the middle of it
then yeah people are just automatically
kind of doing their I'm sure we said
this before and I know we talked about
earlier but like when I would say
something on the radio and task unit
bruiser when I would say like a
legitimate thing Manny would happen if I
got on and said everyone get to building
34 now people would go and I one of my
favorite things to do one of my favorite
conversations to have on the radio with
with either you or stoner was like I
remember you'd be like you'd say hey
Jocko we got another move or where I
want to take down building 34 and I'd
come up and go do it but that was all
I'd ever said I can do it just like go
because I'm not trying to talk right I
got these guys got their situations
handled hey he's going outside of it
something that we planned hey jock I
want to build a move to building 34 and
take that thing down do it nah well why
do you want to do that you know why he
wants to do it cuz he's got a good
reason he's not asking me that cuz it's
a fantasy that he thinks it's gonna be
cool no there's a reason and he'll
explain that to me later and if it was
something where he's like I want to you
know start doing jumping jacks out here
then I might ask why because that
doesn't make much sense to me but to say
hey wouldn't a weird hip building 34 as
well what if we're doing burpees what
would that make more sense that that
makes a little more sense a little more
sense than jumping jacks yeah like that
that actually worked it worked for us
when use when you said some of the radio
let got it we're good like it was
decision made everyone's on board and I
think it's it's something that you've
got to you've got to focus on what like
when the leader talks it should matter
and and I think you can be you got to be
really careful about that
and I've certainly been a key violation
here that is like going off a to dip in
too many different directions but that
you did extremely well attacking a
bruiser and it works and every leader
should be very Congress to them yeah the
less you talk to more people listen all
right next
Shh in a in a middle management position
what's the best way to support the
company and leadership you work for
while still showing your fellow workers
they are supported and appreciated I
work in surgery at a large hospital with
an even larger corporation this is one
of those things I remember saying I'm
sure I got this from hackworth but it's
one of those things that I've said so
many times I actually probably forget to
even give credit to Acworth but you know
when problems little problems will arise
up the chain of command and I'd be like
everyone hates the echelon of command
above them right that's the way it is
like and that's just the way it is
that's the way it is it's always they
don't get it it's always they don't
understand unless you get somebody that
really knows how to explain and
communicate down the chain of command so
that everyone understands why they're
doing what they're doing that's what
this is that's exactly what this is I do
what's the best way to support the
company leadership is to take what the
company and the leadership of a company
says and translate it to the Troops in a
way that they understand and that means
something to them right so you go to a
big meeting and you know like let's say
an all-hands meeting for a company and
and the CEO is saying hey we made you
know we made 87 million dollars last
year profit and if all the frontline
troops are in there they're like well
that's cool but I didn't see any that
reflected him my paycheck by the way you
gave me a $4 raise over the last three
years how about some of that 87 million
kick it down to the people so that's
problematic cuz we aren't explaining hey
good that's it that literally that
statement right there will actually make
people mad the the CEOs thinking
everyone's gonna love me because I'm
telling how
but we are as a company all everyone's
thinking is well then why can't you
afford to buy me that piece of gear that
we need on the front lines what's your
problem
that's so you actually think you're
helping but you're actually hurting
unless you can explain to people look we
made this much profit here's how it's
gonna benefit us as a company and you as
a frontline troop by us making this much
money it means we can grow these areas
it means we can bring on more people
that means everyone in this room right
now in the next three years you're gonna
have an opportunity to be in a
leadership position that's what I'm
talking about that's why we're trying to
grow that's why we're trying to do
better by the way as we this is snowball
and even more because now we're putting
more money into advertising we've got a
whole advertising campaign that's going
on we've invested a bunch of money in
that and it's gonna bring us more
business and that means the jobs that
you think might not be stable your job
if you don't think it's stable it just
got stable because we have the capital
to get this machine moving even faster
so when you do that when you explain to
the troops why something's happening it
makes them understand and it shows your
people hey you're supporting are there
times where you should push back yes
there are and if something makes no
sense whatsoever you should raise your
hand and say hey let me go let me run
this up the chain of command let me run
this up the chain of command and explain
why this isn't a good idea and that way
you can go and when you get the reason
because there'll be a reason and it
might not be the best reason but it'll
be a reason and you go back to church
and say hey here's why this is going on
this is what's happening this is the
decision they made and you know what
we're gonna do our best to execute it
because that's what we do we make things
happen we're gonna get it done
boom and we get a great we've got a
great depiction of that in the talking
about being humble not passive and
pushing back where it matters in the
dichotomy leadership that's that whole
section is talking exactly about that
it's a very hard thing for people and
that the basis of this question though
is the US versus them right front lines
versus corporate headquarters and and
you've got to defeat that if you're a
good leader you got to recognize look
we're all on the same team we can't do
what we need to do without having the
support and you know the resources and
the approvals of plans from the
corporate headquarters you know and it
pretend quarters that often times so not
only are is there frustration up the
chain there's also frustration down the
chain you hear that all the time like
will the front lines they don't really
get it you don't get it over there well
listen from the front lines is where the
actual mission gets won or lost yeah so
you you gotta you might want to have
them on board with the program so you
got to make sure that you know that it's
got to if you want a successful team you
can't have us versus them every time a
big win on board for the big one yeah
the full-metal-jacket right what's your
problem son why don't you get on board
for the big win and and you think oh
well if I'm the general and I'm telling
this young guy that's got a peace sign
on this helmet that represents the
dichotomy maybe that's where I learned
the word dichotomy from that represents
the dichotomy of what does he say that
economy yeah this is the duality
totality of man yeah you're right that
represents the duality of man why don't
you take that thing off and get on board
for the big win and that's such a great
line from that moon join the team son
get on board for the big one has such a
great line from that movie because
that's exactly what we're talking about
that does absolutely nothing for that
frontline soldier that goes okay you're
saying that and I'm literally burying
people right now in this situation and
so for you saying that to me means
nothing in fact it shows how completely
freaking out a touch you are and so they
did a great job in that movie of
representing that through one single
line it why don't you just get on board
for the big win no no actually why don't
you lead how does that sound
so communicate up and down the chain of
command make sure people know why and
tie in why it matters to them next
question in extreme ownership you talk
about being close with the team but not
so close that they forget who's in
charge or that the good of the team
suffers how do you overcome the
isolation of leadership what strategies
did or do you employ to avoid the
isolation becoming an issue this is an
example of I'm gonna take this to the
extreme hey I'm not gonna be too close
to my people guess what I'm not talking
to them right I'm not gonna speak to
them I'm
I gotta maintain a distance I gotta and
it's it's obviously not true it's
obviously not true and I think you know
that the relationship that you and me
and Seth and the that we all had was
clearly this right I wasn't alone
I wasn't isolated as the leader because
we were all bros and hanging out and now
did it start off like that no you know I
as we always talked about like I come
across a hacker or a style of like hey
we're not gonna joke around for at least
whatever six to eight weeks to make sure
that these dudes are good to go and that
that they understand where I'm coming
from and and that's cool but once we get
through that okay like then it's like
open up a little bit then it's like open
up a little bit more and then it's open
up a little bit more so that you're not
isolated at the top because not only is
it important that you're not isolated
that's like that's like a a marginal
thing what's more important is what I
talked about earlier is if you if life
can't come to me and say hey man hey I
don't agree with this plan or more
importantly hey Jocko here's what's
going on with the troops right now
here's what's going on with the
mentality here's what's going on with
the morale if he can't knock on my door
and say that to me then that's a real
problem because now you know I'm in the
dark on what's happening inside inside
with the troops which is problematic
yeah I think it's this to me sounds like
I was think about this question and it
sounds to me like maybe a junior leader
that was promoter of the shame cuz
that's where you really feel like when I
go from you know the assistant platoon
commander where I'm like kind of one of
the boys and I'm you know we're we can
you know it's kind of I can kind of play
interference with it with the officer in
charge and the platoon commander now of
a sudden I get promoted it's you
recognize instantly there's a little bit
of difference
you've got to maybe kind of distance
yourself slightly from where you were
previously and recognized when you took
over Charlie put through now as the
platoon commander when did you realize
that you needed to transition from being
one of the boys until being the oh I
seen that there was that the gap was
gonna open up a little bit was it as
soon as you took over it was pretty
quick cuz I've been to buds and steel
qualification training you know escuchar
advanced training with with several guys
and I knew these guys very well and you
know I think we had big house party
hanging out
a good time and and everybody's over at
my house and all of a sudden I realized
something I did all the time you know as
an assistant platoon commander and all
of a sudden we're in at work you know
the next week and I got a got to make
some some tough calls and we got to get
you know drive the standards a little
bit higher where we're at and there's
some pushback and you realize like okay
when it's it when it's time to give
people some bad news or say hey we're
not doing this because we should we need
to fix that and they kind of give you
the leg hey bro you know what are you
doing Friday yeah then it's then you're
like okay I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to distance a little bit but the
isolation you should never be isolated I
think that's one thing that you know I
remember coming into your office and I'm
come in and hang out all the time in
your office you know you're you you you
come in and hang out in the platoon
space I mean I've come you know we see
each other in the gym with like we're
always trying to find a way to like hang
out and talk and and it was even even
when you know Seth's no home was it all
the way across the other side of the
city I mean I you know he'd still
connect with him and talk to him on the
phone and was well and yeah well I
talked about all the time on the a nd VT
yeah you guys do you guys talk but but
haven't but even even meet you know yeah
we'd always he came by like we'd always
try to try to get together and talk to
each other and catch up whether it was
in the chow hall or or you know in a
platoon space and you know guys like I
remember Tony would come in there on I'd
come in I'd walk in and I'd see the wind
plan written up on chocos whiteboard and
task unit bruiser Bertoni had written
down all the things that we needed to do
to win in Ramadi
pretty harsh yes yes y'all probably on
the level like Genghis Khan would
certainly angry red planet weird you
know
hey man but we are as its mayor we are
we are joking laughing about that this
is the relationship JA go ahead you know
I would me but with with other leaders
in the task unit and and I think you
have to have that I mean you've got to
have a you've got to have relationship
with your people you can't think that I
can't talk to anyone I can't interact
with anyone I think there's you're gonna
be unsuccessful as a leader you know if
you try to roll that way it's it's not
gonna work
yeah I think we're you might feel what
might feel like a isolation which is
definitely true and this is the burden
of command right like guess what you're
friends with Lafe your friends we
Seth you're friends with Tony you're
friends with these guys but at the same
time like oh the burden of command is on
you and it's gonna be it's gonna be you
you're gonna you're gonna bear that
right in your platoon it's like hey you
got your sister platoon commanders
you've got your platoon chief you got
your LPO but when something goes wrong
if something goes wrong if you if
there's a bat if something happens on a
mission that goes bad I'm not talking
I'm not I'm not looking at the assistant
platoon commander um I'm looking at you
that's the burden of command that's so
that thing yeah that's that there's one
man that stands on the carpet right
that's that's the way it works and
sometimes being one man that's that's a
little bit of an isolating feeling - and
to help help you understand our leading
petty officer Charlie - awesome awesome
amazing see I love the guy and hopefully
could be on here one of these days after
he wrote his retirement comes one of
these days but he was I'm we were we
were up in Nevada training and we took a
couple days to go snowboarding mmm which
was an awesome deal and he like we're in
the van he looks around he like sees me
he's like I'm not the senior guy and so
he's screaming at laughing about how
awesome it is to knock me to senior guy
because he knows the burden of command
is now with me and now with him if guys
get in trouble or do some simulation to
those yeah yeah which is while you're in
Tahoe guys getting in trouble and doing
stuff stupid it's probably a fairly
likely thing to happen highly probably
that's one of my favorite trips that I
did multiple times yeah so that's it man
build relationships and at the same time
you are when you're in charge you're in
charge and there's a little bit of
that's called the burden of command
embrace it and you've got time for one
more question
here you go in life and Jacko's opinion
you've been excluded from this one angle
Charles so they don't want your opinion
what has changed or what point do you
find you need to emphasize more from
when you wrote extreme ownership to now
well this is a softball question that I
selected until all the easy ones well
yeah I think the answer this one's
pretty obvious that's why we wrote the
book that kata me leadership I mean this
is this is what we had needed emphasize
more and just as you know you talked
about this when we were talking about
jaws to you know whether or not you know
the sequel is gonna be as good and you
know we have we had pressure to write a
book extreme ownership did very well
like hey you guys you're right out of
the book we didn't want to write another
book until we actually had something
useful to write about that would impact
leaders for the better help them be
better people better leaders lead better
teams lead better lives and and that's
what this is the dichotomy leadership
answers the most difficult challenges
and obstacles that we see leaders face
and I think that three years you know
one thing that extreme ownership did for
us is I mean if our company blew up as a
result
Ashlin front we were able to work with
so many more leaders and so many more
companies and we got to see this over
and over and over and over and over
again and and this this is capturing
those those issues that we saw and then
the solutions to solve those problems
through leadership yeah I think it's
gonna be pretty evident I think it was
cool how it revealed itself as the
subject matter of the next book I mean
we we like you said business blew up yes
we were busy we weren't really sitting
there going okay what should the next
book would be about what should the next
book be about we actually didn't even
think of we weren't even thinking about
it and then as we started saying and hey
you know people don't understand this as
well hey we we should have added more
chapters about the dichotomy we should
and it's like over time all the sudden
became very it became completely
blatantly obvious that what people
needed help with was this most difficult
thing which is achieving the balance of
all the different dichotomies of
leadership and that's why I wrote the
dichotomy leadership gets on
right on well we're just hitting that
two-hour mark which means we only have
two hours for Ecco to talk about support
you said echo is excluded for that last
question but I want to know what your
answer is that go from oh yeah what I
learn extreme ownerships come out since
the podcast is launched okay so the the
main thing that sticks out main thing is
that is what people seem to ask you all
the time is what do I do when other
people aren't taking extreme ownership
and here's the thing when you're outside
and listening you're like aha I see what
you know I it's almost like a funny
question right because it's like what do
you call that like ironic all right kind
of were they like what are you doing
other people but it's you the one's
supposed to anyway so that's sick but
the reason that that's significant is
because when you're in the situation
that's exactly what it feels like you
can't like really see it so I'm saying
so you got a detach which kinda kind of
sheds more even more light on the
importance of detaching alright so it
kind of feeds in it into itself but so
yeah when you're in the situation and
you have to essentially take ownership
when the other person should be taking
ownership but factually in your mind the
other person heed to take responsibility
for this that's the time you gotta take
responsibility of it yeah hard to like
it's hard to really grasp that in the
beginning I thought well that was pretty
cool recently we got an email from a guy
that's overseas running a company and he
he listened to Dave Burke and and he'll
do yeah good deal Dave and I think it's
a great example to say can you take
ownership of the weather right cuz the
obvious answer is no I can't take
ownership of the weather and I talked
about this on that podcast is like well
actually you can because you can come up
with contingency plans you can come up
with
you can stage your force forward closer
and so anyways this guy in his company
it's a software type company and
implementation company and they
piggyback on a big giant you know one of
the biggest companies in the world and
that biggest company in the world one of
the biggest companies in the world made
some errors and it messed up their
platform and they went to their client
and said hey the platform got messed up
it was the big
they did this this and this wrong and
the people were like oh okay
you know I guess and then he went home
and he listened to that podcast and he
went yeah I screwed up because that's
hey the biggest company in the world is
still easier to control than the weather
right and so he went back to the company
and he went back to the his client and
said you know what it wasn't their fault
it was our fault it was my fault
here's some things I'm gonna put in
place so that this never happens again
and all of a sudden the attitude
completely changes and the client is
super happy and is all of his team also
cuz what does that do to your team when
you blame when you blame the weather
your team just goes okay we got a
permanent excuse now well it wasn't good
no seas were too big wind was too high
cloud cover was too low whatever the
case may be
you got a permanent excuse now because
you can't control the weather actually
wrong wrong we do control the weather we
we will set up our missions will set up
our contingencies that no matter what
the weather does where to accomplish the
mission no matter what our big will
never wouldn't no matter what the big
platform that we rely on no matter what
happens with them we're gonna be in
control that's how we roll get some that
feedback was phenomenal and to hear him
you know saying that his clan was like
I've never seen anyone handle a problem
like this before you guys have done an
amazing job and it's another example of
how you're scared to take ownership by
taking ownership your living trust your
healing trust and you win it when you
take ownership and you actually get the
problem soft going for speaking of
ownership and taking ownership maybe I
could take ownership of you know support
sure be happy to how to support you know
sure all right those selves cells the
path really that's what we're supporting
the path right well maybe you're on the
path you not on the path alright if
you're not on the path I'm actually
somebody who tested a picture of just a
sign that said please stay yeah
legit exactly right and I was gonna say
if you're not on the path we're not
talking to you but if you're not on the
path I'm I think we're talking equally
mm-hmm
maybe more so I want to say more so but
really if you're on the path I'm talking
super loud too so eagerly I think I
don't know maybe we'll think about that
more later um we'll go into origin right
our company origin main dot-com jeez
rash guard for jujitsu lathe talked
about jujitsu earlier awesome stuff yeah
Georgia makes the best stuff it's I've
got I think I have like five different
you you have the first version very
first origin guy I ever touched was
yours
I've never reco you is what wristing
yeah muster and yeah neoreul when you
see the weave yeah like on the origin
that pattern in there you can understand
do they do you have do you have
currently do you have any other gi's
that are not origin I have three g's I
have one non origin okay if two orgy
I'll put that on put that on in like is
a threat and I'm serious good that's
good I mind I was like oh should I keep
this or not I put put on you know one of
my old and like bro I can't I can't wear
this like he doesn't right donate those
keys I even even at the end at the white
belt level I can totally tell that I
roll better in my origin games oh yes
now that's that's the whole belt good
he's rolling Dona I know but there's
something about like that it actually
has give to my shoulders I can move in
in a way that like I with my other geese
it's it's really tight I can't move and
I feel like I don't
I actually I seem to be more successful
what percentage of increased performance
do you achieve wearing an origin at
least nine actually that is a good point
because I had a gives like my second key
ever and I was like hey that one looks
cool cuz it had like cool designs on or
whatever and it was like thick material
for some reason I thought that beefy
thick material looked cool so I got it
and it I'm not gonna I'm not gonna name
the name of the brand so doesn't matter
but
um yeah when I'm rolling it feels like
more claustrophobic like with which we
know you have an issue with I did before
yeah back in those days
Greg did I carry you of classroom hi I
think you were contributed to the cure
of my classroom with Andy and we were
rolling with the ghee and I was trying
to do like a crazy
whatever lapel not lapel what's that
what's the down here like the bottom
part of the jacket yes Andy and house
and I was almost just working something
and I couldn't I didn't have enough
jacket out and I was like I'm whispered
to him like I'm and have origin to make
you a thing for him to win him do and
I'm alone with yes and then he was doing
he you know how people drag your jacket
and they get between your leg on a
single you know what I mean yes he's
doing he's like that's his game right
now and I told him I'm gonna make I have
origin make a key from me somebody
arrest tailor tear we got to do it but
that makes sense though if you roll
better like if you're feeling like
you're kinda in a straight I'm not
saying other brands feel like straight
down I'm not saying that but I'm saying
if you have a specific feeling while
you're rolling and it's amaze me and I
forget like me it's not very flexible
it's it's awesome and it's a definitely
prettier game and it helps you and you
look good by the way I said no also
speaking of looking good and feeling
good and comfort they do have joggers
and t-shirts and whatnot most
comfortable joggers still to date in my
experience it just means a lot are you
getting chocolate aware this job even
though I was gone apparently the
undisputed champion of comfort apparent
according to connoisseur and and rash
guards I I wear I wear the rash guard
when I'm working out some days the days
I wear it when I'm working out it's long
sleeve is when I'm doing a lot of stuff
on the Rings so my arms don't get all
chafed up which is the comfort move if
you break it down just saying yeah well
I'm a food in that let's say the results
of not having the rash guard in or
impedes or gets in the way of your
functionality or something like this you
know you know how like like some people
over there were straps or
where I don't know one of the ol Ike
some of its in a full powerlifting suit
yeah not yeah like that full thing yeah
but that's more of like you know I don't
know when someone else has to put your
belt on you you know when they're like
heaving there's two or three people
trying to heave the belt in a position
yeah I guess no I'm thinking more cos
like compare that to your rash guard
scenario right it's like something
something that's gonna like you know
people wear those things on their hands
so they don't get blisters oh great so
the blisters sure you could power
through it but if it was measurable
would it get in the way of the
performance the blister if you do rip a
callus which sometimes people post rip
Callison and I get it like you got a
good workout in but guess what you're
tomorrow's workout it's not gonna be as
good especially right yes
tomorrow on the dead list with the rip
callus from pull-ups to make it said
make sure you don't rip the question is
I'm stoked you got after it yeah but I'm
not stoked in the next day when you're
like not being able to live yeah so
let's say they wore gloves or in your
case you wear the rash guards is that
technically for comfort or is it for you
know tape functionality may appreciate
yeah yeah I don't I don't know if I
could see fit to say that I've witnessed
you do anything for comfort as far as
getting after it goes okay that's cool
yeah also what supplements and
supplements yeah chuckle what's up we
got joint warfare we got krill oil
we got discipline joint warframe krill
oil for your joints and now surprisingly
alternate fact curcumin is also good for
your brain function apparently which I
could use all the help I just I just got
an order in I'm a new new replacement
order enforcing krill oil and join
warfare wait you're on the discipline
train right now I'm on the discipline
train I got at this moment I see you got
some just right or right at this moment
unfortunately lost discipline earlier
yeah dude this is weird lack of
discipline yeah you know
he he he made discipline and then he
lost his discipline I mixed up a huge
bottle of this but a Jacko's house and
then as we were leaving to come here I'm
like what the hell did I do with it I
was like life where is your discipline
your dog is probably getting after it I
just like on level 19 but you got it
back though I see so uh yeah
Molk can forget about the milk which is
the tastiest of all tasties restless
discomfort so yes yes and I'll be honest
with you
now maybe I'd burn myself out a mint but
I've been going I've been going Richter
on TV so that Y okay so the chocolate or
the peanut butter chocolate comes in
right Oh big hype we're talking about it
when's it coming it's supposed to come
in this one week you took what a few
days later whatever the big height comes
in everyone's fired up I'm one of those
people from my boom pilots so I'm
probably a chocolate peanut butter now
pounding it mock train full speed so
after a while I'm in the peanut butter
you know one and and then I look and I
still have that mint one one day I go in
I'm gonna make it I see the mint one in
the mint when it looked like he was
looking at me like did you cheating on
the man you know so I put them in one
back in and I was reminded that that is
my favorite one flavor yeah yeah I I but
they put a taste yeah see it's kind of
like it's kind of like it's it's
ridiculous
you know it's ridiculous that you can
just completely eat that and just enjoy
it
yeah my son has been posted I've been
retreating if someone's been posting
like milk recipes oh yeah and they're
all these really I haven't tried any of
them yet because I just that's not my
thing
what do you just put it straight milk oh
no I just put in milk but this guy is
creating like mmm like cookies balls
cookies all kinds of crazy mold
conventions yeah and they look good and
he's saying they taste good so I don't
know I'll give him a try
he'd what you do is or what I wound up
doing is because peanut butter is like
in - in my opinion undeniable
in life peanut butter the flavor it's
actual peanut butter sometimes you can
mix one scoop in one scoop you know
peanut butter chocolate and the mint
chocolate cool but you've done that oh
yeah I'm not all yeah that's like
crossing the streams in ghostbusters oh
yeah and you know that's all they want
the movie that's how they did the bad
date across the street do is you put
peanut butter with the milk one let's do
that report back okay if you want
Heywood at this time invite everyone to
the immersion camp but it's sold out so
I'm sorry
sign up next year early and come hang
out with us at the immersion camp check
yes
also good way to just to support Jocko
has a store it's called Jacko's door and
this is where you can get apparel
apparel is cool right yeah
fashion is not not cool okay cool a pair
of us but if you want to represent it is
not there you go
but you will look fashionable if you
accept the terms chocolate doesn't maybe
not yeah oh good you look good though I
think I don't know that's a matter of
opinion but if you want to represent
that's where you can get shirts rash
guards hats trucker hats namely label
trucker hat or flex fit where you at
chug Arab City there you go dang one
flex fit oh yeah interesting
I'm not again actually report back yeah
I want to know what sells more trucker
hat or or flex fit that's an interesting
question on that and also got a long
comment about hoodies a guy from
Michigan mmm-hmm that works construction
said hey Jocko just letting you know in
Michigan we do need lightweight hoodies
Oh boom so yeah like everything I've
ever said has been disproven now this is
one man's opinion yes you know well
here's the thing about that when you
kind of did take a step back it's like
you you just went extreme you weren't
wrong you just went extreme that's all
you know you
so this guy in Michigan he had the
balance because he knows the extreme he
knows about the values at big foodies in
Michigan I gotta say for the folks in
Michigan they're like being up there in
North Dakota it was to work like when
you go to Alaska and you you know it's
like pretty cool out and you got your
jacket on he's looking around there's
dudes and like t-shirts it's all
relative to this like in Maine just
where I just wear a heavy sweatshirt all
day long I mean all winter long maybe
have Cajun you gotta film on some kind
of a parka you know to parkas being from
Hawaii not some so what'd you do with
your car on the trucker had to flex foot
debate Oh like flex but i think is great
i like flex flex foot hats but i will
say i got a large melon being able to
adjust is is important particularly when
you're fishing and you're rolling out
and your hat gets blown off and it's
then it's soaking wet like my the
largest melon i've ever seen on a human
there was a guy on the special boat
teams who was a great dude he was a big
I'll just say Polynesian maybe he was
Filipino maybe he was Polynesian I don't
know but he was something like that
right
Pacific Islander I guess his head was so
big okay you know a protec helmet you
know but you don't approach that I was
like a pro tect bike helmet he had one
of those for for riding in the boat for
like doing operations where you gotta
wear a helmet he had one of those and he
had all the foam inside of it all of it
was gone and we still had to like
basically grease up his head to get the
thing on this it would be it was crazy
how big his head was huge and he was a
great dude but he had a huge head he had
no protection he's had a little thin he
only wore nothing cuz it was a part of
the rules he could have just called he
gives a look I don't need a helmet my
dick get away from me I gave up this
stupid helmet on people all right so you
would need the Flex fit you know a lot
of flex in that fit you need a lot of
flex and I said yeah I'll take the truck
it would fit nonetheless
anyway like I said Jocko store.com this
we can get all this cool my opinion cool
some when you may have minor stuff to
new stuff is on there yeah jockle
white t there's a shirt so my brother
has a pepsi shirt and a Garbett remember
Garbage Pail Kids yes
you know the little cards they're like
so my twin brother G he has a garbage
pail kid shirt and you'd think as an
adult you're like alright but it kind of
you know it's kind of cool it's cool
shirt and then you get your Pepsi shirt
like even if you don't drink that it
just looks cool right so we got a
chocolate white t-shirt so you look Jack
so that was not I thought I actually
gave you credit in my mind for having an
original cool because I thought it's
yeah the thing is it does the the fact
is that concept is a very cool concept I
didn't do it because very perps you do
it so let's do it that's not why I did
it I think that that concept is cool you
know Chuck white either get this shirt
and it's a t-shirt
we call those layers anyway you got some
new stuff on there um check out check
also good way to support is to subscribe
to the podcast if you haven't already on
iTunes Google Play stitcher you know
wherever you where we listen to your
podcast just subscribe that's a good way
to support it leave a review and you
know you want your kids to listen to
this podcast but you know you can't
because sometimes it's completely
inappropriate but for that reason we
have the warrior kid podcast and that's
questions from Uncle Jake or for uncle
Jake and so you can get that one to the
youtube we also have a youtube channel
that you can subscribe to hey subscribe
you know what let's not do this you
never watch a YouTube video in the end
at the end it goes please subscribe and
click or whatever right click we're not
gonna do that
yeah we're not gonna do that and you
think buddy and I don't wanna go into a
whole deep thing here but it seems like
as a consumer mmm as an audience member
of viewer of videos whatever you and it
does defeat the whole purpose of
clicking like right when you like this
how many people do you think at the end
of a youtube video where it says click
subscribe now to watch more awesome
videos how many people does that
convince push them over the edge and
they just can't stop
I don't know but from what I've read
before it's like they recommend that
like that you do that as a content
creator is what they call it they say
yeah hey just ask those people will do
it kind of thing it's kind of like hey
you can't get it if you don't ask but it
does kind of give you this kind of
underlying feeling of like you're asking
me to do something that's made to be
organic it's made to be if you liked
this video you press like that's what
that thing is made for and now you're
asking me to violate that whole reason
that it's me so you want me to do it as
I favor like you ain't gonna like you
might like I was watching your video cuz
I thought we were just cool I see and I
thought we were just having a little
moment right a little two minute and 30
second moment and then I get to the end
of it and now y'all so you're coming out
safe asking me to do this and do that
now I see what it was it was a setup and
I'm not saying that's what people are
doing I'm not saying that's what you're
doing if you're doing that I'm just
saying as a consumer or the viewer
that's what it kind of feels well we'll
try and avoid that try to you I just
sayin hey on this podcast go there and
subscribe to it that way you won't get
bothered with a little thing from echo
at the end that says please click
subscribe to more videos from echo drop
the most how should I say accurate for
like a better term way to put it if you
didn't know that we have a youtube
channel we do if you didn't know you
could subscribe to it boom now you do if
you want to subscribe you can't believe
without saying obviously same thing with
the light like I like it that's a
YouTube that's you to grab to it yeah
it's true also if you're working out you
want to switch it up and talk about on
it so on it calm /jo here's the thing to
which I kind of forget to say you get
10% off if you go to this slash choco so
go on it doc on slash chocolate so when
you're buying your kettlebells primal
bells legend Bell's rings and you know
battle rules stuff like that go on it
calm flash chocolates where you can get
10% off really good stuff they're good
info as well psychological warfare is an
album with tracks we're working on
number two right now so we'll make that
happen
and I'm getting some good requests via
the interwebs about what should be on
there
so itunes google play mp3 platforms you
can get that psychological warfare album
with trucks but what is that for though
we're not gonna let you say it everybody
knows what was it for do you know what
it's for yes it's to combat those
moments of weakness that we all have I'm
gonna make a special on to the track
about how to not say something that has
been said did oh yeah course that's
something that's not been said yeah beat
a dead horse
yeah I'm just saying if this is the
first time they heard it they're gonna
be war fur I know what regular the
traditional psychological warfare is
it's kind of like if I kept saying to
hey jock a white tee oh you know what
you can you can deadlift eight thousand
pounds and I kept saying that over and
over again and never stop saying it yeah
that'd be kind of like what you're doing
yeah but so it seems like it from your
perspective but from the perspective
someone just tuning in you're not too
good 138 podcasts the ears of thing and
they started here oh they did there go
listen to another one they'll hear it
eventually you know and then they'll
start to hear it over and over again but
from saying as an individual account
which means more in my opinion yeah okay
I think this can all be set over the mat
yeah
Amazon cans you can get cans people
don't notice and get cancer Jocko whitey
it's stop drinking other energy drinks
that are filled with sugar and other
crap and get yourself to Dhaka let me
ask you this so you know how there's
these pre workouts yeah right you know a
pre-workout feels right it's like super
like it's I don't know a pre workouts
are but I know the one they have k they
have like a bunch of caffeine whatever
the label is real shiny a lot of the
time you know ones that have a light
label that's really all right so let me
ask you this if I have a jock whitey
in a can yeah it's cold yeah right very
refreshing and then I put some of that
energy pre-workout in it since it
doesn't have that much caffeine and
maybe looking for some caffeine if I put
that pre-workout stuff in the in the jaw
kuwaiti how much of a violation is that
on a scale from one to ten I don't think
it's a violation but I would just use
discipline you can put discipline at
Rockaway yeah but that's just another
micro dose of caffeine no no you don't
want caffeine right whitey that's the
thing sure there's taste got jammed up
there's 60 milligrams of caffeine and
chocolate II can't that's that's enough
let's say hypothetically again
hypothetically one was looking for more
than 60 milligrams get-get Greek fire
okay so you know a Greek virus yeah
origin Greek fire from origin which has
caffeine in it it's like a it's like a
fat burner right so if you get that that
is caffeine in it and it'll get you you
know get you what you need
all right so the violation level for yes
sure I I drink a lot of coffee and a lot
of caffeine yeah that's Iago Whitey's
got funny cat paper minutes yeah would
you I'll tell you what I like about it
with a cans a particular it's been crazy
hot in Texas the summer yeah and just
just pull like a freezing cold without
the I found myself on my truck that's
you know 125 degrees we're sitting on
the Sun and crack open a super cold I'm
rolling down the road it's pretty legit
mellow I'm gonna make it you know what
I'm gonna make is I gonna make something
that like this that you can drink before
you go to bed at night oh yeah
just cuz cuz I can't I mean I want
sometimes it's seven or eight o'clock at
night and I think I'm half crack one
open but then I think now then I'll be
all wired up all night yeah yeah like
you put some sort of uh because there's
like you know tea would he call the tea
that you brew before bed makes you smell
kind of that yeah chamomile tea we got a
situation here
lady melanin strong
you made your bread no you don't know
all about I didn't know about it what is
it chamomile yes so you could take that
approach meal right you could see you
could call it so we get all choco
chamomile tea oh wow
you know you could call it that if you
want yeah I would try to just call it
like well I'll figure something out but
I will do that something because I do
need something at night warm hot in the
summertime or hot in the wintertime but
you could drink it cold that's tasty
because that's the thing about the the
jakka white tea is the taste is good
like we had this I thought were you'd
come with us if you had a can of jakka
white tea and a can of the most sweet
like it's like doctored up thing that's
supposed to taste delicious which would
you pick
I'd pick joggle white tea all day long
because the taste is you know when you
you know when you realize that Gatorade
no offense against cater it no a little
bit of fence crude you know when you
realize that Gatorade doesn't actually
quench your thirst like when you're I
don't know I think I was it's 20 right
and I was real thirsty and I drank a
Gatorade and I was like why am I still
thirsty yeah that cuz there's syrup in
there or whatever doesn't work good mmm
ah quite well this further back to the
energy or the pre-workout mix in the
teeth scenario this person that we're
talking about didn't finish it because
it did jam up the whole tea scenario
okay it was like a theoretical check
yeah there it is boom
Chuck white tea outstanding Hey books we
got way of the warrior kid books where
the warrior kid and marks mission those
are good books for kids to read just
talking to a teacher out in the gym yeah
teaching the book eighth grade if you're
wondering about well how old is an 8th
grader 11 12 11 12
yes so 11 12 year old definitely in the
whole team sometimes when I meet someone
and their kid is 8 or 10 I just think
your kids in the zone and they dig it so
way the warrior kid had marks mission I
just just started reading the way your
kid to my son does he get a three right
story does he get it we got we got about
30 pages into
fired up and you want to go out do some
pull-ups it's funny they get certain
parts right you know the the grander
kind of messages may not you know
compute quite yet but yeah they'll get
certain parts so they'll like like when
this part comes yeah
stoked the feedback on that one also
diss political freedom Field Manual
there's a manual about how to get after
it and the audio version is not on
audible it's on iTunes Amazon music
Google Play and other mp3 platforms so
you can make it specifically we did that
yeah maybe took a little financial hit
whatever
want people to be able to use it as an
alarm clock in their phone or a ringtone
mm-hmm so that's what you can do there
those are a few books then we got then
we got extremely ownership obviously
which Jaco and I wrote been out for
three years now we have a new new
edition out and of course dichotomy
leadership which we were just talking
about and that's for it's available now
for pre-order it'll be released
September 25th super excited about that
looking forward to all your readers out
there providing some feedback on that
and I hope this is at least as useful to
you and in your lives professional
personal lives as extreme ownership so
go get some dichotomy leadership to find
the balance you also live to talk to me
about the difference between first a
dish and let's say fifth a dish of a
book which would you rather have which
was which would I rather have yeah I'd
have to go with the first edition that's
sort of the standard it's the standard
is there anyone run around going man I
wish I had the night the day yeah I
can't wait for that fourth edition yeah
that it is pretty cool with extreme
ownership with where there I people
still come up to us and have you know
with it with a the cot and the original
paper this was printed on was not very
good for extreme ownership you know it
doesn't have the and it doesn't have the
number one New York Times bestseller
across the top so every once while we
still see some of those like wow that's
it that's a that was a first for ending
run I just I just did that the other day
so a girl came
when I was signing her her first a dish
and there's there's there's four
editions that you could possibly have
there's more than that but the first one
that came out is white and there's no
sticker on it soon as the as soon as
that made New York Times bestseller they
went and got stickers it says number one
New York Times micelle and they put them
everywhere because it's a it's an
advertising gig right but there's so the
people that got the first 10,000 copies
it's just a plain first dish so I know
there's people and then you got then
then they got the stickers on it so
you're still early then you got the one
that actually has printed on the cover
number one New York Times bestseller
blah blah blah and then finally we get
to the fourth the fourth version which
is the black cover back in black which
is way we have to say that it's clearly
different where different avenues
coolness yeah it's a different Avenue of
coolness but still the first dish we
always like the first a dish and if you
so if my point is if you want the first
dish you got to order it pre yeah
otherwise you're gonna get some other
you know you'll get one that says
something else on it be all different
and we'll know what a meet you I'll just
obvious be oh you want me to sign them
yeah that's cool I'm glad you got in the
game eventually no I appreciate it
a salon front if you if you're
interested in coming and bringing us in
to talk to your your leadership team
your frontline troops your mid-level
managers whatever maybe that's what we
do with echelon front is we solve
problems through leadership everything
that we wrote about extreme ownership
all the things that we just talked about
from dichotomy leadership isn't what we
do it's me and Jocko we launched this
company going on seven years now and we
work with a lot of company sense and now
you know in addition we've got to me and
Jocko we got JP Danelle we got Dave
Burke we got Flynn Cochran we've got
some Mike Sorelli and we just picked up
a new member of our team main gun Mike
bomb a company commander with us in
Ramadi outstanding outstanding guy
awesome team of folks and so you're
interested in what we do through H la
fronte go hit us up at Ashlyn frotcom
also we got the muster which is
two days Leadership Conference seminar
gathering that's what we all gather it's
a leadership muster that's what it is
October 17th and 18th up in San
Francisco all the other ones have sold
out this is a six muster they've all
sold out this one's gonna this one's
gonna sell out even earlier actually I
think so we're way ahead of schedule if
you want to come to it extreme ownership
calm you can come to the muster and then
also for our military law enforcement
firefighters Border Patrol paramedics
first responders anybody in uniform
we're launching our first ever first
responder or military uniform wearing
focused leadership gathering and this is
we're calling the roll call roll call
zero zero one first-ever is gonna happen
September 21st in Dallas and this thing
is for it was it was by request we
worked with so many different first
responders and you know fire fire
departments and law enforcement groups
and police departments federal state
local we worked with all levels of you
know of these groups and we've had so
many folks say hey can we have a a focus
leadership conference just for us and
that's what this is so we've got several
hundred people party already signed up
for this thing this is this is for you
guys this is for all you listeners that
are interested in this we try to make it
at a price point that was much more
affordable than the muster so that we
could we could have as many folks attend
as as could come and we hope you come
from far and wide to be they're going to
be talking about the importance of
training the importance of dealing with
what you deal with every day and driving
those standards and and pushing your
team and leading up the chain as well as
you know all those kind of specific law
enforcement firefighter first responder
military focused issues that we can
really dive into you know we don't have
talking about the business leader stuff
because this is for you guys
that's what it's for so if you're
interested in that if you're on the
fence if you're thinking about it come
join us for roll call at in Dallas
September 21st and of course you've
heard on this podcast we launched
a new company a subsidiary company to
exelon front it's called exelon front
over watch our EF over watch and you can
check that out at at EF over watch comm
it's it's a great company designed to we
one of the biggest things that that we
see from the companies who work with
this people ask us where can we get
people like you where can we get folks
with a mindset of extreme ownership and
so we started that in the special
operations world and the goal of
overwash is to take Special Operations
veterans and combat aviator veterans and
place them in companies with place them
in companies who are looking for people
with that mindset and EF overwash is is
is something I'm super excited about we
have a massive demand signal right now
frankly we have a lot more clients that
are reaching out these companies that
are seeking folks to place in and offer
them job opportunities and we have a lot
more clients than we have on the
candidate side so if you're a special
operator and you're about to be retired
or are leaving just leaving the military
or I've left even a few years ago or con
the combat aviation side go to EF
overwatch comm fill out the the
application there and start the
paperwork because we've got with there's
an awesome opportunity here for some
great companies with some great
leadership positions and some promising
promotion opportunities in some
companies that exhibit extreme ownership
that have that as part of their culture
so don't miss out most opportunities go
to the website
input your information EF overwatch calm
and come get in the game there's a lot
of a lot of great work to be done a lot
of massive opportunity out there
companies need good leaders come and get
it and until we see you at the muster or
we see you at roll call or we see you at
the immersion camp doing those uzhitze
if you want to ask us questions or if
you want to give us answers you can find
us on the interwebs on Instagram life is
at real-life babban
on twitter and on that phase a belief is
at lief babban and of course on all
those echo is at echo charles and i am
at jakka Willick echo anything else
negative Lafe any closing thoughts good
to be back on with you guys again
somebody gets up always good to have you
and thanks to everyone for listening and
supporting this podcast especially to
those people that make this podcast
possible the people that make this
podcast possible and it's not some long
list of sponsors the people that make
this podcast possible is our military
our police law enforcement firefighters
Border Patrol paramedics other first
responders without you protecting us
from evil abroad and keeping us safe
here at home we wouldn't be able to do
what we do so thank you for doing what
you do and to everyone else out there
whether you are making something or
baking something whether you're serving
food or serving warrants whether you
work in a bank or you build banks if you
wear a suit and tie or you wear
coveralls and a hard hat no matter who
you are and what you do do it to the
best of your ability take pride in your
work
and be the best you can but at the same
time stay balanced be aggressive but not
reckless take ownership but empower your
team be humble but not passive be
disciplined but be free balance the
dichotomies of leadership and the
dichotomies of life and as you do that
keep getting after it
and until next time this is life and
echo and Jocko out